Hello, listeners. We've got something special for you today. What is it? It's a podcast called Smart List. What happens? Don't turn the channel. We've got a real fun chat. Who's on today, Jay?
大家好，听众朋友们。我们今天准备了特别节目。是什么呢？是一个叫《Smart List》的播客。会发生什么呢？先别换台。我们有一场非常有趣的闲聊。今天是谁来呀，杰伊？
We've got a special guest. The audience, you know what we're talking about. But two of us do not. We've got a special guest that the audience, you know what we're talking about, but two of us do not. We've got a really great one. Who are the two guys that don't know who the guest is? Stay tuned to find out. Stop, stop teasing the audience here, Jason. Welcome to Smartless.
我们迎来了一位特别嘉宾。听众朋友们，你们都知道我们在说什么。但我们俩不知道。我们迎来了一位特别嘉宾，听众朋友们，你们知道我们在说谁，但我们俩不知道。我们请到了一个非常棒的嘉宾。哪两个人不知道嘉宾是谁呢？敬请期待，马上揭晓。行了，别吊听众胃口了，杰森。欢迎来到Smartless。
Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
欢迎来到Smartless。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. I'm going to unmute our surprise guest feed. Just give us a little clap if you're with us. Jesus, that's a powerful clap. We were talking, Will, before you came on, that Jason, well, first of all, we did this photo shoot yesterday and Jason found one gray hair and pulled it out. Because people think that Jason dyes his hair
聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。聪明的。我要把我们的惊喜嘉宾静音取消了。如果你和我们在一起，就给我们鼓个掌吧。天哪，这掌声真带劲。威尔，在你上来之前，我们还在聊杰森，首先，我们昨天拍了一组照片，杰森发现了一根白头发，然后把它拔了。因为人们觉得杰森染发，
and he does not dye his hair. I do sometimes, but you don't either, Will. Yeah, he doesn't dye his hair. I don't, but I have these. It's unbelievable. I have these grays on my temple now. All right, what are you gonna do for those, for the project coming up?
但他其实没染发。我有时会染，但你也没有，威尔。对，他没染发。我没有，但我有这些。这太不可思议了。我现在的太阳穴上也有这些白头发。好吧，对于接下来要进行的项目，你打算怎么处理这些白头发？
Leave them. Yeah, man. Yeah, just keep it. Exactly. Why would you try to trick someone into thinking that you're different than you are, Sean? Yeah, I'm not gonna use makeup. There's only one Sean Hayes in the world.
留着呗。是啊，兄弟。对，就留着。没错。肖恩，你为什么还要试图糊弄别人，让他们觉得你和实际不一样呢？对，我才不会用化妆品呢。世界上只有一个肖恩·海斯。
Why would you pretend to be anyone else? We love Sean Hayes. And you look, by the way, Jason, to bring it up, you look great. You don't need to do it. What did I tell you yesterday? You have the face of a 13-year-old. Yeah. Yeah, well.
为什么要假装成别人呢？我们爱肖恩·海斯。而且顺便说一句，杰森，你看起来真棒。你根本不需要这么做。我昨天跟你说什么来着？你长着一张13岁少年的脸。对。好吧。
You'll never look old. I know, okay, I was gonna make another joke about some famous pop star. Look at how gorgeous Will Speck is with his gray hair. Look at how gorgeous Richard Ehrlich. Richard Ehrlich, the best realtor in Southern California. What about John Slattery, you know?
你永远都不会显老。我知道，好吧，我本来想拿某个著名流行歌星开个玩笑。看看威尔·斯佩克顶着一白发有多帅。看看理查德·埃利赫有多帅。理查德·埃利赫，南加州最棒的房地产经纪人。还有约翰·斯莱特里，你知道吗？
The most handsome actor going. Richard Ehrlich. I'll do it. All right, maybe I'll let it go a little bit. Yeah. All right, apologies to the guest. Here we come, tighten up. Gang, now this isn't a great intro,
最帅的在世演员。理查德·埃利赫。我来吧。好吧，也许我让它稍微长一点吧。好吧，向嘉宾道个歉。我们来了，振作点。伙计们，这开场白可真不怎么样，
it just doesn't fit what this guy does. But I was rushing this morning. So today, we've got a fellow that's done, I apologize for the chainsaw outside my house, God damn it. We actually can't hear it. Good. So today we have a fellow that's done more with his 41 years
根本配不上这家伙的成就。但我今天早上赶时间。所以今天，我们请来了一位……真该死，我得为我房子外面的链锯声道歉。其实我们听不到。太好了。所以今天我们请来了一位，在他41岁的人生中取得的成就，
than we have with our combined 150. He's acted in film, television, been nominated for the most prestigious awards, he's written plays, he's directed films, he's a father and a husband, and he's here to tell us how he does it all. Gang, let's get to it, it's Jesse Eisenberg. Come on, Jesse.
比我们150岁加起来还要多。他演过电影、电视剧，获得过最负盛名的奖项提名，写过戏剧，导演过电影，是个父亲也是个丈夫，他今天来跟我们分享他是怎么兼顾这一切的。伙计们，话不多说，他就是杰西·艾森伯格。来吧，杰西。
Oh, nice. Jesse, come on, Jesse. Hi, hi, hi. Hi. Thank you so much for the introduction. Oh my gosh, you're very nice to meet you. Sorry I clapped so loud, Thank you so much, yeah. It did not.
哦，太棒了。杰西，快来，杰西。嗨，嗨，嗨。嗨。非常感谢你的介绍。天哪，很高兴认识你们。抱歉我刚才鼓掌声音太大了，非常感谢，是的。根本没有。
Do you have large hands? Let's see your hands. No, I think I was like, I think I didn't understand where I have to be in relation to this microphone. You know what I mean? Oh yeah, I know it's difficult. They just gotta know that their mics are hot.
你的手很大吗？让我看看你的手。不，我觉得我好像，我觉得我刚才没搞懂我该怎么配合这个麦克风。你知道我的意思吗？哦，对，我知道这很难。他们只是得确保麦克风有声音。
This is a new mic. I'm working with a new mic. Do you do a lot of microphone work? Do you have a podcast? Everybody knows. No, no, no. Nor do I do a lot of mic work. I mainly use just like my headset headset but today, you know your podcast is worthy of this road NT USB mini
这是一个新麦克风。我正在用一个新麦克风。你经常做和麦克风有关的工作吗？你有个播客吗？大家都知道。没有，没有，没有。我也不经常做麦克风相关的工作。我主要就用耳机，但今天，你知道你们的播客配得上这个Røde NT USB mini。
Trying to get free shit. Yes. Yeah, we bought it. You don't have to sell it Look who's even across the pond. I take my road I'm in England. Oh, that's why this yeah get ready to be showered with Mike I'm in England. Oh, that's why that's, yeah. Get ready to be showered with Mike. Yeah, right, exactly. Now, are you, and god damn it, you're in England doing what? Doing something else that is very difficult?
想占点便宜是吧。是的。对，我们自己买的。你不用帮它宣传。看谁都在大西洋彼岸。我带了我的Røde麦克风，我在英国。哦，这就是为什么……准备好被麦克风洗礼吧。我在英国。哦，这就是为什么，是的。准备好被麦克风洗礼吧。没错，正是如此。那么你，该死的，你在英国干什么？在做另一件非常困难的事吗？
I'm in the dressing room of the Graham Norton show. Oh, the Graham Norton show? Are you really? This is not Chatty Man, right? This is, I'm doing a meta press junket. I'm doing it from the press, yes. Wow. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
我在《格雷厄姆·诺顿秀》的化妆间里。哦，《格雷厄姆·诺顿秀》？真的吗？这不是《Chatty Man》吧？这是，我在跑元宣传通告。我是从宣传通告那边……是的。哇。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
You're about to go out on a talk show and you're recording a podcast. Yeah. I mean,, wait, wait, wait, wait. You're about to go out on a talk show and you're recording a podcast. Yeah. I mean. But this is good, because I can stay in this kind of like self-indulgent place. I could just talk about myself for the next 48 hours and I'll be okay.
你马上要上脱口秀节目了，结果你还在录播客。对。我的意思是……等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你马上要上脱口秀节目了，结果你还在录播客。对。我的意思是……不过这挺好的，因为我可以保持这种自我沉溺的状态。我可以接连48小时只谈论我自己，我完全没问题。
You work so hard, like I can only do one thing a day and the rest needs to be played. Here's an idea, here's an idea. Just go with me. And Jesse, you can throw this out if you'd like and also welcome to Smartless. And Jesse, you can throw this out if you'd like. And also welcome to SmiteList. But I just want to say this. Why don't we, the four of us, come up with a fake story
你工作太努力了，我一天只能干一件事，剩下的时间都得玩。有个主意，这里有个主意。听我的。杰西，如果你愿意，也可以把这个扔掉，另外欢迎来到Smartless。杰西，如果你愿意，也可以把这个扔掉。另外欢迎来到Smartless。但我只想说这个。为什么我们四个不编个假故事，
for you to tell on the Graham Norton show? That we will all be. Oh yeah. Right, because he won't know now until it comes out, which is way later. Oh, go Will. So okay, wait, this is like a prank pulled on me? Or him, or what?
让你在《格雷厄姆·诺顿秀》上讲呢？我们全都会……哦，对。没错，因为他现在不会知道，直到节目播出，那都是很久以后了。哦，威尔，加油。所以，等等，这是一个针对我的恶作剧？还是针对他，或者什么的？
On him or on the world? Well you're going to be in on it. It's just like a prank pulled on me or him or what? On him or on the world? Well, you're gonna be in on it. It's just like a fun little Easter egg that a couple months from now, people go. That's interesting. Do you wanna do a whole story or should we do like a word? Or we can do a word. Or you could do a word or you could do that,
针对他还是针对全世界？好吧，你会参与其中的。这就像是一个针对我或他的恶作剧之类的吗？针对他还是针对全世界？好吧，你会参与其中的。这就像是一个有趣的彩蛋，几个月后，人们会说。这很有意思。你想编个完整的故事还是说个词？或者我们可以说个词。或者你可以说个词，或者你可以那样，
actually both of your legs have been replaced. Let's do the word. This does bring up a good point, Will. Will, unless you've got something in mind here. Yeah, I got it. It does bring up a good point, Will. Unless you've got something in mind here. Yeah, good. It does bring up a good point that maybe Tracy is unaware of. Jesse Tracy is Sean's sister.
其实你的双腿都被换掉了。我们就说个词吧。这倒提,出了一个好点子，威尔。威尔，除非你心里已经有什么想法了。对，我想到了。这确实提出了一个好点子，威尔。除非你心里已经有什么想法了。对，很好。这确实提出了一个崔西可能不知道的好点子。杰西，崔西是肖恩的姐姐。
Who was in this concert. Hip to all the business tree stuff. The inside, she's on the outside, sure. And so for Tracy, before we do talk shows, the night time set, you do what's called a pre-interview, where you talk to the segment producer and you come up with stories and crap you're gonna say, and kind of work out your answers.
她对所有娱乐圈的事情都很门儿清。内幕消息，她是个局外人，当然。所以对崔西来说，在上脱口秀、晚间节目之前，你要进行所谓的“前采”，就是和环节制作人聊天，编出你要讲的故事和废话，差不多把你的回答先捋一遍。
Which I imagine you've done, Jesse, for this show. Yeah. Not for us, but. There's a big pre-interview for this. No, this one's a weird one. The one with this is weird. They're basically like, we're on with Kieran, who's in my movie, and then like, I'm with Daniel Craig. You're on with other people.
我想你这次上节目也做过这些，杰西。对。不过不是针对我们。这次有个很大的前采。不，这次这个挺奇怪的。这个节目真的很怪。他们基本上是说，我们和基南一起上节目，基南演了我的电影，然后还有丹尼尔·克雷格。你和其它人一起上。
And so the pre-interview, exactly. And so the pre-interview with this one was like, Daniel was shooting in Italy. What was it like shooting in New Orleans 15 years ago on a movie? Basically, the link is that we both didn't shoot a movie in New York City. And so, like, I realized the stories they're going for
所以前采，没错。所以这次的前采就是，丹尼尔在意大利拍戏。15年前在纽奥良拍电影是什么感觉？基本上，这其中的联系就是我们俩都没有在纽约市拍过电影。所以，我意识到他们追求的故事，
are just these incredibly tenuous links with the guests who have nothing in common. It's never. Right, right. Yeah. You know what's funny is that both you, ironically you, Kieran and Daniel have all recently, or all recently,
其实就是嘉宾之间那些极其勉强的联系，明明毫无共同点。从来都不是。对，对。是啊。有趣的是，你们俩，讽刺的是你、基南和丹尼尔最近都，或者说都刚刚，
It might have been the last three guests we've had. Yeah, on our show. No. Yeah. Is that true? Well, that's the thing. That's the thing. Kieran, what a pain in the ass he is.
这可能是我们最近遇到的最后三位嘉宾了。对，在我们的节目上。不对。对。是真的吗？好吧，就是这样。就是这样。基南，他可真是个讨厌鬼。
Jesus Christ. He's just an asshole, this guy. I mean, so negative, not cheery at all, no energy at all. No hobbies. No hobbies, nothing. Wait, I can't tell if you're kidding because actually that does describe a version of me that I know very well.
天哪。这家伙简直是个混蛋。我是说，太消极了，一点都不阳光，完全没有活力。没有爱好。没有爱好，什么都没有。等等，我分不清你是在开玩笑，因为那确实描绘了一个我非常熟悉的版本的我。
He's like the greatest. We love it. He said very nice things about you as well. We loved having him. Maybe it's something about the fact that everybody, that now, that doing the Graham Norton show, you can't do it until you've done Smartless. I don't know.
他简直太棒了。我们很喜欢他。他也对你说了非常好的话。我们很喜欢他来。也许是因为大家现在都有个共识——上《格雷厄姆·诺顿秀》之前，你必须先上《Smartless》。我不知道。
Yeah, work on it. No bad ideas, no bad ideas. Right, something like that. Listen, I'll figure that out in the moment. Don't you worry. But literally the order was Daniel, Craig, Karen, and then you on our show. And now that's crazy that you're all on the same panel on that show.
对，琢磨琢磨。没有坏点子，没有坏点子。对，诸如此类的。听着，我到时候见机行事。你们别担心。但字面上的顺序确实是丹尼尔·克雷格、基南，然后是你上我们的节目。现在想来，你们所有人都在那个节目的同一个嘉宾席上，这太疯狂了。
I mean. We just said Sean. No, I know, but that's crazy. Yeah, but we can continue to analyze. Yeah, it's amazing. Was that literally the last, no, no, it wasn't literally the last three. I think it was.
我是说。我们刚说了肖恩。不，我知道，但这太疯狂了。对，但我们可以继续分析。对，太神奇了。那真的是最后，不对，不对，那不是字面上的最后三个。我想是的。
No, it wasn't. Oh, no, there was. There was Tito and Taro in there as well. Yeah, there was, nevermind. You know, Kieran is like the, oh, he's like the biggest fan of your show, and just a very uncomfortable thing happened once is where he told me, we were on a plane and he said,
不，不是。哦，不，里面还有蒂托和塔罗。对，还有，算了。你知道，基南就像是，哦，他简直是你节目的超级粉丝，有一次发生了一件非常尴尬的事，他告诉我，我们当时在飞机上，他说，
like he loves your show so much, he said, except one episode and he told me the name of the guest and it actually does escape my memory now. I forgot who he said was like a not a good guest. And then I ran into that person and I was so nervous that I had this information in my head that they were the worst guests on Smartless. And so I said to them,
他特别喜欢你的节目，他说，除了其中一期之外，然后他告诉了我那个嘉宾的名字，不过我现在确实记不清了。我忘了他说谁是个糟糕的嘉宾了。后来我遇到了那个人，我当时特别紧张，因为我脑子里有这个信息，知道他们是《Smartless》里最差的嘉宾。所以我对他们说，
Kieran said you were the best guest on Smartless. And they were like, oh really? And you don't remember who it is? I don't remember who it is. Alright, wait, let me get to my questions. I've got great questions. I'm an incredible interviewer. By the way, it's so nice to meet you. I've been such a fan for a long time.
基南说你是《Smartless》最棒的嘉宾。然后他们说，哦，真的吗？你记不得那是谁了？我不记得那是谁了。好吧，等等，让我来问我的问题。我有很多好问题。我是一个超级优秀的采访者。顺便说一句，很高兴认识你。我一直是你的超级粉丝，很久了。
Oh my God, me too. Of you, of course. Jesse, we met briefly. We met each other, Will, yeah. Wait, what? Where was it? It was in LA at a studio, but we were doing a promotional video with Jimmy Kimmel for Batman.
天哪，我也是。当然是你的粉丝。杰西，我们之前有过短暂的见面。我们见过面，威尔，对。等等，什么？在哪儿？在洛杉矶的一个片场，但我们当时在和吉米·法伦——哦不，吉米·金梅尔一起为《蝙蝠侠》拍宣传视频。
Yes, yes! You remember that? That was so weird, yes! It was so weird. With Ben Affleck. That's right, it was like a reverse engineered idea. Cavill. Yeah, that's right, it was like they were meeting
对，对！你还记得？那太诡异了，是的！太诡异了。和本·阿弗莱克。没错，那是一个倒推出来的创意。卡维尔。对，没错，就像他们在一场派对上相遇，
at a party and I was playing the bad guy. And yeah, you came in afterwards and I think Jimmy Kimmel came in afterwards as Batman or something, I can't remember it. He came in, he was saying Batman and Superman and then. And then Lego Batman. And then I came in and said Lego Batman
而我演的是坏人。然后你后边进来了，我想吉米·金梅尔作为蝙蝠侠什么的后边也进来了，我记不清了。他进来了，他说着蝙蝠侠和超人，然后。然后是乐高蝙蝠侠。然后我进来并说我是乐高蝙蝠侠，
and then Ben said something like, you're not really supposed to be a real Batman, and I said, well, you might want to check the box office. Oh, God. Yeah. Or something. Yeah. Here's what I was left with,
接着本说了一些类似“你其实不配当一个真正的蝙蝠侠”的话，我说，“好吧，你可能得去看看票房成绩了”。哦，天哪。是的。或者诸如此类的话。是的。这是我当时留下的印象，
and tell me if you agree with me on that, Jesse. Sure. I was really impressed with Jimmy Kimmel's acting. I thought he did a great job that day. Really? And I told him that. Yeah, I would hope so, yeah. That's not exactly the thing I walked away with.
杰西，你告诉我你同不同意我的看法。当然。我对吉米·金梅尔的演技印象深刻。我觉得他那天表现得很好。真的吗？我还告诉他了。对，我希望如此，是的。这可不完全是我当时的感受。
I can't remember, was he really good? Wait, like how so? Like he seemed genuine? Well, in that, I guess, look, the bar was low because I thought he would be fucking terrible. Oh, got it, and he was engaged. He was like generally engaged. He was engaged.
我记不清了，他真的很棒吗？等等，怎么个棒法？就好像他很真诚？好吧，在这个方面，我猜，听吧，期望值本来很低，因为我以为他会演得该死地烂。哦，明白了，而且他很投入。他感觉真的很投入。他很投入。
He seemed like he was really listening in the moment. Yeah. No, that's true. I guarantee you he's a great actor. You know, you can just tell with some people that they just kind of know the way they come across and therefore they're able to sort of calibrate that and guide that, you know, and incorporate lines into that. Like, I bet he'd be a great actor.
他看起来像是真的在当下认真倾听。对。不，确实如此。我向你保证他是个好演员。你知道，从某些人身上你就能看出来，他们很清楚自己给人的印象是什么样的，因此他们能够相应地调整和引导这种印象，你知道的，还能把台词融入其中。比如，我敢打赌他会是个好演员。
But Jesse, when did you start, we all know you as a very accomplished actor, and I am also like Sean, and Jason, I'm a very big fan of your acting. I think you're really, really good at it. Oh, God, me too, of course. But as a writer, when was that that you, did you always write,
但是杰西，你是什么时候开始……我们都知道你是一位非常有成就的演员，我也和肖恩、杰森一样，我是你演技的超级粉丝。我觉得你演得真的、真的很好。哦，天哪，我也是，当然。但作为一名作家，你是什么时候开始的？你一直都在写作吗？
or is that something that came later? No, I've been writing plays in New York for like 20 years. But this is like... And I've had some popular plays or whatever, but nothing to this level. I had two plays that were gonna go to Broadway, were both canceled the week before we put out the press announcement for different weird reasons.
还是后来才开始的？不，我在纽约写了大概20年戏剧。但这是像……而且我有一些挺受欢迎的戏剧什么的，但没到这个级别。我有两部原本要上百老汇的戏剧，都在我们发布新闻稿的前一周因为各种奇怪的原因被取消了。
So this is the first thing that I'm really getting like more attention and it's quite surreal because I feel like, well, I've been doing the same thing for 20 years, but people like this one and it makes me wonder where I went wrong 20 years ago. Wait, tell me what it is. Tell me what it is. What is?
所以这是我真正受到更多关注的第一部作品，这感觉相当超现实，因为我觉得，好吧，我20年如一日地做着同样的事情，但人们偏偏喜欢这部，这让我不禁怀疑我20年前究竟哪里做错了。等等，告诉我这是什么。告诉我这是什么。什么是什么？
You're doing a play right now? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You're talking about a movie with, with, yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no know sketch comedy when I was younger. No way really really? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, of course Yeah, when I was 17, I put together like a packet for Saturday Night Live actually when I was 16
你现在在排话剧吗？不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。你说的是一部电影，带有，带有，是的。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不尔，其实我年轻时写过素描喜剧。真的假的？真的吗？真的。真的，真的，当然。我17岁的时候，甚至在16岁的时候，我还给《周六夜现场》写过一叠稿子，
I wrote a script about Woody Allen and it got sent to him It was about like a fictional version of him now at 16 Which is what I was changing his name to Woody Allen and it got like sent through various channels to his lawyers who then sent Me a cease and desist letter But then you ended up doing three films with him. Did it come up? I did movies with him. It came up once, we were on a press junket.
我写了一个关于伍迪·艾伦的剧本，还寄给了他。那是关于他当时虚构版本的剧本，我当时16岁，我把他的名字改成伍迪·艾伦，然后通过各种渠道送到了他的律师那里，接着律师给我寄了一封停止侵权信。但你后来演了他的三部电影。这事提过吗？我和他合作过电影。提过一次，我们在跑宣传通告的时候。
He's so uninterested in anybody else. You know, so like, I don't mean that as a criticism. He's just like, he's just like, basically I knew what would happen is that somebody during press would bring it up because it's like a cute story that's on the internet and he would go, oh, that's interesting. I never, didn't know that,
他对除了自己以外的任何人都毫不关心。你知道的，我这么说并不是批评他。他就是这样，基本上我知道会发生什么，就是在宣传期间会有人提起这事，因为这是网上的一个可爱的小故事，然后他会说，“哦，那挺有意思的。我以前不知道”，
and would never think about it again. And I knew, I can go up to him and say, hey, that was weird, right? He would just have no, he just doesn't have any interest in stuff like that. I think he's just been like so famous and celebrated for so many years that he's uninterested in like the public persona.
然后就再也不会去想它了。我知道，我可以走到他面前说，“嘿，那挺诡异的，对吧？”他完全不会有任何感觉，他对这种事情就是一点兴趣都没有。我想他大概是因为成名太久、被追捧了太多年，所以对公众形象已经不感兴趣了。
And so, no, he didn't care about that, and we didn't share a nice laugh or a drink. I love the idea that you're like waiting to get a response to your submission and the response is a cease and desist. Yeah, yeah. But it's also like you bring up like, hey, so you sent me a lawyer letter, what about that? No, I don't know anything about that.
所以，不，他根本不在乎这个，我们也没有一起开怀大笑或者喝上一杯。我喜欢这种脑洞：你一边满怀期待地等着投稿回复，结果收到的回复居然是一封律师函。对，对。但这也挺像那种情况的，你提起这事：“嘿，你给我发过律师函，那件事怎么说？”“不，我对此一无所知。”
Well, the lawyer is his producer. Like, I got to know the lawyer. But I'm sure there were 10,000 letters, like they were sending that every day to everybody who wanted to make a movie about him. I remember I was, you know, I got home from school one day and my dad said, we have good news and bad news. I was like, what's, he's like, what's, I said, what's the good news?
好吧，那个律师其实就是他的制片人。我是后来才认识那个律师的。但我确信当时有上万封信，他们每天都在给所有想拍关于他电影的人发这种信。我记得有一次我放学回家，我爸跟我说，我们有好消息也有坏消息。我说，怎么了？他说……我问好消息是什么？
He's like, we heard from Woody Allen. I was like, what's the bad news? He's like, you might have to get a lawyer. And he sent me the thing and I framed it right away. It was so exciting. You know, wow. That's pretty good. So when you're writing a play versus a film to a ding-dong like me,
他说，我们收到伍迪·艾伦的回信了。我说，那坏消息呢？他说，你可能得找个律师了。然后他把那封信拿给我，我立刻把它装进框里挂了起来。太让人激动了。哇。真不错。所以当你在写戏剧和写电影时，对于像我这样的笨蛋来说，
it would seem that writing a play is easier because it's just dialogue. And a film, you've got to incorporate what the visual component is going to be as well and sort of imply some of the, you know, the inner thinking of the characters as well and all that. Is that fair to say that writing a screenplay is more difficult? I mean, no, I think it depends on the project. And, you know, you could make the same argument that you have to keep people's attention for two hours on one set. And, you know, there's something incredibly difficult about that.
似乎写戏剧要更容易一些，因为它只有对白。而拍电影，你还得把视觉成分结合进去，并且还得暗示出角色的内心想法等等。说写电影剧本更困难，这话公平吗？我的意思是，不，我觉得这取决于项目。而且，你也可以提出同样的论点，你必须在同一个布景下用两个小时抓住观众的注意力。而且，你知道的，这其中有着极其困难的地方。
Whereas a movie, you can have music come in and you could have close ups and you could re-edit it within an inch of its life and it could turn into something that's test screened a bunch of times. So like, no, I mean, my plays have been basically like four scenes total, so like a half hour scenes and you know, so like a half hour scenes for a two hour play. And I like that my mind works in that way to like keep scenes going. So my struggle with like movie writing is to just make sure the scenes are not seven minutes long.
相比之下，电影里你可以加入音乐，可以用特写镜头，可以把电影剪辑到极致，还能把它变成一部经过多次试映的东西。所以，不，我的意思是，我的戏剧基本上总共就四场戏，也就是两小时的戏剧里有几场半小时的戏。我喜欢我的大脑以这种方式运作，让戏份持续下去。所以我在写电影时面临的挣扎，就是确保场景不会长达七分钟。
Holy shit. JB, he just clowned you, dude. Why? Why? You just got totally clowned because you had a... I'm so clowned I didn't even realize. You didn't even realize? No, I'm kidding.
天哪。杰·布，他刚才狠狠地调侃了你一把，老兄。为什么？为什么？你被彻底调侃了，因为你有一个……我被调侃得甚至都没意识到。你甚至都没意识到？不，我开玩笑的。
But I thought there was, I was clowning him, but I thought there was a gentle, I was doing it gently. It's a gentle clown. You were clowning him with a baby wipe. Speaking of clowns, your mother started another silly internet thing, you know, because I do deep research on Wikipedia.
但我以为那是，我是在调侃他，但我以为那是一种温和的，我是温和地进行的。这是一种温和的调侃。你用婴儿湿巾在调侃他呢。说到小丑，你母亲又在网上搞了什么愚蠢的恶作剧，你知道的，因为我在维基百科上做了深入研究。
Yeah, yeah, it sounds like you read that first paragraph. Yeah, yeah, it's right up top. Fucking Jesse, I want this income once a week, and just come in, set J.B. straight, and then be like, I gotta go. He read the snippet from the Google search engine, where a million things come up, and he read the snippet. Now, the directing thing,
对，对，听起来你确实读了第一段。对，对，就在最上面。该死的杰西，我真想每周拿一次这份收入，然后直接出场，把杰·布驳得体无完肤，接着说：“我得走了。”他读了谷歌搜索引擎上的摘要，就是那种会弹出上百万条结果的摘要，他就读了那个摘要。话说回来，导演这事儿，
are you loving the directing thing as my, and I apologize, I bet you've gotten this question a thousand times, are you loving it more or less or the same as writing and acting? Maybe a little less, only because it's such a managerial thing thing as you know. Well, I don't know actually what your experiences have been, but for me, it just felt like I was just aware constantly on set of somebody's plane maybe being delayed.
你更喜欢当导演，还是更讨厌，或者跟写作和表演差不多？我打赌你这个问题已经被问过一千遍了。稍微少一点，仅仅因为这就像你知道的那样，是一件非常考验管理能力的事情。好吧，其实我不知道你的经历是什么样的，但对我来说，我只是在片场时时刻刻都意识到某个人的飞机可能晚点。
Like my experience, and when I'm writing, I'm sitting in a library by myself and acting, it's like kind of an emotional private experience that you can have. And then I just remember, like, I spent the day thinking about this person's hair person flying in from England, and if there was rain in England, they were gonna be late, and then I don't think the actor would come to set. And I was like, this was the least creative thought
比如我的经历，当我写作时，我是独自坐在图书馆里；而表演，它是一种你可以拥有的那种私密的、情绪化的体验。然后我只记得，我花了一整天的时间在想这个人的美发师是不是从英国飞过来的，如果英国下雨的话，他们就会迟到，然后我觉得那个演员就不会来片场了。当时我就想，这是我一生中有过的最缺乏创造力的想法，更不用说是在一部电影的片场了。
I've had in my life, let alone on the set of a movie. Yeah, exactly. That's so fucking interesting. That's such a great point. Right, right, right, right. Does that ring true for you? Yes, it can, but then I just make sure I hire correctly, you know, when it comes to line producers and ADs
对，没错。太他妈有趣了。这真是个绝佳的观点。对，对，对，对。这戳中你的心声了吗？是的，确实如此，但后来我确保自己雇对了人，你知道的，不管是制片主任还是助理导演，
and stuff that you really, you know, they sort of, their sweet spot is managing. Right, that kind of stuff. Do you ask JB, do you ask them to protect you from information that you? No, I actually want to hear about it all, I just don't want to have to fix any of it. Yeah. Right.
以及诸如此类的事情，你真的会发现，他们最擅长的就是管理。对，诸如此类的事。杰·布，你会要求他们把你和这些信息隔离开来，不让你听到吗？不，其实我都想听，我只是不想去解决其中的任何问题。对。
I get that. Wow. I get that. So you don't take on for no apparent reason at all the anxiety of their jobs? I do to the extent that it affects the harmony on the set. That's the part I get really passionate about. Everybody deserves to have a great work experience. Yeah, me too.
我懂。哇。我懂。所以你不会无缘无故地去承担他们工作的焦虑喽？只要这会影响到片场的和谐，我就会承担。这就是我真正充满热情的部分。每个人都应该拥有一段棒极了的工作体验。是的，我也是。
Jesse, never having met you before, but I've seen tons of your work. Do you think I should dye my hair? Is that your question? Yeah, I heard about the sides. Sean, you look amazing. You look amazing. Doesn't ache you.
杰西，虽然我们以前从没见过面，但我看。过你大量的作品。你觉得我应该染发吗？这就是你的问题？对，我听说过两边头发的事。肖恩，你看起来棒极了。你看起来棒极了。不觉得疼吗？
Yes. Sweet little baby boy. Listen, I was sitting there in silence just evaluating all of your temples, and I think you all look great in your different ways. I'm in the, my piece is getting washed so I've got the lid on. Your piece is getting washed.
对。可爱的小甜心。听着，我刚才就坐在那儿默默无闻地评估你们所有人的发际线，我觉得你们每个人以各自不同的方式看起来都很棒。我正在……我的假发正在清洗，所以我把帽子戴上了。你的假发在清洗。
You know what is that, Dave? Is that a hood or what? Yeah, it's a shitty hood, there we go. Oh, it's a hood. Oh, look at that, oh, it's shorter than I thought. Okay, yes. So I'm gonna make a guess about you and you tell me if I'm way off or not.
你知道那是什么吗，戴夫？那是连帽衫还是什么？对，是个烂大街的连帽衫，就这样。哦，是个连帽衫。哦，你看，哦，比我想象的要短。好吧，是的。所以我要对你做一个猜测，然后你告诉我我是猜得离谱还是挺准的。
Capricorn. Libra. You seem, I've seen interviews, I've seen your work, you seem extremely intelligent, you're very cerebral, and you speak very quickly. Why'd you say seem? Okay, sorry, keep going. Cerebral.
摩羯座。天秤座。你看起来——我看过采访，看过你的作品——你显得极其聪明，非常理智，而且语速非常快。你为什么说“显得”？好吧，抱歉，你继续。理智。
And so am I right in guessing that if, that one of your pet peeves is people that can't keep up with the pace of your intelligence? Oh, God, not at all. No, I feel mortified and pretentious when I open my mouth. No, I- Oh, really? Yes, I'm aware that I probably sound like annoying to many people. No, no, you sound brilliant.
所以我猜得对不对：如果……你的一个烦恼就是别人跟不上你聪明的节奏？哦，天哪，完全没有。不，当我张嘴说话时，我只觉得丢脸和虚伪。不，我——哦，真的吗？是的，我很清楚在许多人听来我可能很讨厌。不，不，你听起来才华横溢。
What music? How dare you? It's classical music, turn it up. It's classical music. Yeah. Yeah. That's all I listen to. Okay, because I do, because I have a short fuse if I'm focused on something and somebody can't keep up with me, I have a short fuse. Oh God, no I don't.
什么音乐？你怎么敢？这是古典音乐，把它调大点。这是古典音乐。对。对。我只听这个。好吧，因为我确实——因为如果我专注于某事而别人跟不上我的节奏，我的耐心就会变得很有限。哦，天哪，我才不会。
Do you suffer fools? Me, no I have. I've got a tough time with that. Deep shame and self-hatred. I assume everybody else in the world is like kind of right. But what about, how about said differently, what about people who don't work as hard as you at a given moment, especially when you're directing
你对蠢人零容忍吗？我？不，我。我在这方面很艰难。只有深深的羞耻和自我厌恶。我假设世上的每个人其实都是对的。但是，换个说法，那些在特定时刻不如你努力的人呢？特别是当你当导演，
or when you're having to oversee a bunch of stuff and you notice someone's just kind of dogging it. Like does that get at you? I just haven't felt that way ever. I just feel like so indebted to that anybody's coming to the set and waking up at six in the morning, and they probably have a dog that's being left home alone. No, I just don't ever feel that way.
或者不得不监督一堆事情，然后你发现有人在偷懒时。这会惹恼你吗？我从没那种感觉。我只觉得非常感激任何人能来到片场并早上六点起床，他们可能还有一只狗狗被独自留在家裡。不，我从没有那种感觉。
But I think I'm just encumbered with guilt, so like I just wouldn't... I thought I wouldn't allow that thought to come into my mind because I would feel, well, why am I worthy of having that, you know... Oh, okay, got it. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
但我想我只是被负罪感纠缠着，所以……我才不会让这种想法进入我的脑海，因为我会觉得，好吧，我凭什么有资格产生这种想法，你知道……哦，好吧，明白了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
Did you grow up in this city? Did you grow up in New York? I grew up in Queens and New Jersey, so never Manhattan. Oh, you did? Yeah. Oh, wow. That's why I have this neutral accent. Do you live in New York now on the East Coast?
你是在这个城市长大的吗？你在纽约长大吗？我在皇后区和新泽西长大的，所以从来没在曼哈顿住过。哦，是吗？对。哦，哇。难怪我有这种中性的口音。你现在住在纽约东海岸吗？
Yeah, I live in Chelsea. Careful, Jesse, careful. You do? What do you mean with what? He's getting close to the address. Don't give it to him. No, he said Chelsea. He said Chelsea? Yeah, I live in Chelsea. Careful, careful. You do? What do you mean? He's getting close to the address. Don't give it to him. No, he said Chelsea. He said Chelsea. Yeah, yeah, I can tell you the room.
对，我住在切尔西。小心点，杰西，小心点。你住那儿？你什么意思？他快说出具体地址了。别告诉他。不，他说的是切尔西。他说切尔西？对，我住在切尔西。小心，小心。你住那儿？你什么意思？他快说出具体地址了。别告诉他。不，他说的是切尔西。他说的是切尔西。对，对，我可以告诉你房间号。
Don't give him a street. And no, I'm just saying, do you want to have lunch at Cafe Clooney next week? That's all I'm saying in the West Bay. Can we have lunch for a second? Yeah. Why not? Yeah, we could do that.
别给他留余地。不是的，我只是说，你下周想不想去西湾的克鲁尼咖啡馆吃午饭？我只想在西湾说这个。我们能吃一会儿午饭吗？行。为什么不呢？行，我们可以这么做。
Yeah, it's a great place. I'm going to be there if you'd like to have lunch. I'm going to get. You're going to get the table. Let me ask you about this. The amount of focus it takes to write, I've done it once and it was a very long time ago and it was very humbling and I've got a massive amount
对，那是个好地方。如果你想吃午饭，我会在那儿的。我会去拿。你去拿桌子。我问你这个。写作所需的专注力，我做过一次，那是很久以前的事了，非常让人谦卑，我有着极大的
of respect for folks that can fill a blank page. Once you go through that process and you've really, you know, grinded away at the wordsmith of it all and then an actor starts to play with that dialogue on set and starts to kind of go off a little bit and round the edges and, you know, paraphrase a little here or there. Does that, are you good with that or does it make you crazy? And then I've got to follow up to this and I think you know where I'm going.
敬意献给那些能填满空白页的人。一旦你经历了那个过程，你真的，你知道的，对这一切的文字打磨进行了苦干，然后一个演员开始在片场摆弄那些台词，开始有点放飞自我，润色一下边缘，你知道的，这里或那里稍微意译一下。这，你觉得这样可以吗，还是会让你抓狂？然后我还有一个后续问题，我想你知道我要去哪里。
But go ahead. Oh, yeah. So no, as a, like, again, my background is playwriting and no one changes the words ever because when you do a play, I mean, as a, like again, my background is playwriting and no one changes the words ever because when you do a play, I mean as you all know. Well, yeah, that but also like most playwrights are dead so you're just not, theater actors are not in the habit of changing dialogue, you know. And then so this is my second movie and yeah,
但请继续。哦，对。所以不，作为一个，就像，再次强调，我的背景是剧本创作，从来没有人改过台词，因为当你演一出戏时，我是说，就像，再次强调，我的背景是剧本创作，从来没有人改过台词，因为当你演一出戏时，我是说，正如你们都知道的。好吧，对，不仅如此，而且大多数剧作家都去世了，所以你只是不，剧场演员没有改台词的习惯，你知道的。然后所以这是我的第二部电影，对，
I just, yeah, it doesn't, it brings weird to my ear so I don't like it but you know, occasionally somebody's so brilliant like Kieran, as you met, he's so clever and quick and spontaneous. So he would sometimes change a word here and there and it was always really good. You wouldn't come in after a take and go, huh, okay, all right.
我只是，对，它不，在我听来很奇怪，所以我不喜欢它，但你知道，偶尔有人如此才华横溢，就像基兰，正如你所见，他那么聪明、机智又自然。所以他有时会在这里或那里改一个词，而且总是真的很不错。你不会在拍完一条后走过来，然后说，哈，好吧，行。
It's just a script here. Like just gonna double check. Yeah, sorry, I'm just gonna leave it right in front of you just because we don't have a coaster. You must have gotten an old. You must have gotten an old. You must have gotten an old. You read it from a different... Exactly, yeah.
这儿就只有一个剧本。就像只是要仔细检查一下。对，抱歉，我只是把它放在你面前，因为我们没有杯垫。你一定是拿到了一份旧的。你一定是拿到了一份旧的。你一定是拿到了一份旧的。你是从另一份……没错，对。
So then, it wasn't onerous to you to work on social network with Aaron Sorkin's stuff, who is somewhat famously, an um versus uh is sometimes a problem. You have to really stay strict to that. Is that true, was that your experience on that film? And if so, was it a hassle? That wasn't my experience,
所以，在《社交网络》中与艾伦·索尔金的作品合作对你来说并不繁重，他的作品有点出名，也就是“嗯”与“呃”有时是个问题。你必须严格遵守这一点。这是真的吗，你在那部电影中的经历是这样的吗？如果是的话，这算是个麻烦吗？那不是我的经历，
but I don't also think I tried to change anything. It wasn't like I had a clever idea that was like funnier than Aaron Sorkin's joke. You know what I mean? No, but just in an effort to make it sound sort of just naturalistic and my character that's really interesting My character didn't talk in a naturalistic way He was kind of like this like almost robotic presence And so actually for me it felt like this is perfect In fact the gamesmanship of like adhering to this exact thing was part of the character
但我也觉得我没有试图改变什么。我并不是说我有一个比艾伦·索尔金的笑话更有趣的聪明主意。你知道我的意思吗？不是的，只是为了让它听起来自然一点，而我的角色，这真的很有趣，我的角色说话并不自然。他几乎就像个机器人一样的存在，所以实际上对我和我来说，这感觉很完美。事实上，遵守这个严格规定的博弈感本身就是这个角色的一部分。
I just saw it by the way like, like last year for the first time. Oh, really? It was so good. And you got an Academy Award nomination for that, yeah? That's right, yeah. I mean, it's just incredible. So good, right? Shawn's at the official review, so I'm just going to log it.
顺便说一句，我去年才第一次看。哦，真的吗？太棒了。你还因此获得了奥斯卡最佳男主角提名，对吧？没错，对。我是说，这真是太不可思议了。太棒了，对吧？肖恩在做官方评论，所以我正要把它记录下来。
Hey, um... Well, because I was like... Shawn's hot takes. Oh, hang on, there's more. Go ahead, Shawn. So it's a so good ellipsis. Well, because I was like I think I wanted because oh hang on this work go ahead Sean So it's a so good ellipsis I avoided it because I knew there was gonna be a lot of talking in it and then but yeah I watched it and I was like, oh I wasn't this is so fucking I mean, this is yeah
嘿，嗯……好吧，因为我当时……肖恩的热辣观点。哦，等等，还有呢。说吧，肖恩。所以这是一个太棒了的省略号。好吧，因为我当时想，我想是因为，哦，等等，这个工作，说吧，肖恩。所以这是一个太棒了的省略号。我避开了它，因为我知道里面会有很多对话，然后但是，对，我看了，然后我就想，哦，我不是，这太他妈的，我是说，这是，对，
Jesse's interview, but I'm having a tough time escaping from I avoid it because I knew there'd be a lot of talking in it a tough time escaping from, I avoided it because I knew there'd be a lot of talking in it. Yeah. Fucking... Go down that? I mean, if ever there were an example of why we're living in idiocracy, this is it right now. It's a fucking blight on the entire civilization. People like you have fucking encouraged us to know we're in this fucking hole we can't
杰西的采访，但我很难从中抽身出来，我避开了它，因为我知道里面会有很多对话，我很难从中抽身出来，我避开了它，因为我知道里面会有很多对话。对。他妈的……去顺着这个说？我是说，如果有什么例子能说明为什么我们生活在白痴统治之中，这就是此刻。这简直是对整个文明的毒瘤。像你这样的人他妈的鼓励我们知道我们正处于这个我们无法
get out of because you want to drool in front of the fucking television. Hey, Jesse. Anyway. Having seen, having been in the social network, what did it, what impact did it have on you in your regard to social media, to Instagram specifically, social media in general, back then, a few years later, and now?
摆脱的泥潭中，因为你想在狗屎电视机前流口水。嘿，杰西。不管怎样。看过，参演过《社交网络》之后，它对你在社交媒体、特别是Instagram、总的来说的社交媒体方面的看法产生了什么影响，在当时、几年后以及现在？
I mean, I never did it and don't do it, but I don't know, I feel weird like putting more stuff about myself online. Like it's already kind of embarrassing. You know, like it's weird to be a public person in general, so I didn't want to go online, but that's mostly has to do with my just complete discomfort with myself and so like I didn't want to like talk about, you know, I guess things. But, you know, I don't know.
我是说，我从来没玩过，现在也不玩，但我不知道，我觉得把更多关于我自己的事情发到网上感觉很怪。就像已经有点尴尬了。你知道的，总体来说当个公众人物很怪，所以我不想上网，但这主要与我对自己完全的不自在有关，所以我不想去谈论，你知道的，我想是各种事情。但是，你不知道。
I'm suspicious of it for so many other reasons too. And, you know, the movie depicts like this person creating it who does not have like what I would consider like kind of healthy social relationships. And so like if this product is the extension of this person's social behavior, then this is not great. Well, yeah, that's a really good way to put it. In effect, that this person's behavior, this person's outlook on human relationships
出于很多其他原因，我也对它持怀疑态度。而且，你知道，电影刻画了一个创造它的人，他并没有那种我所认为的健康的社交关系。所以如果这个产品是这个人社交行为的延伸，那么这就不是什么好东西。好吧，对，这话说得真好。实际上，这个人的行为，这个人对人际关系的看法
is now being projected. Exactly. As a mode of living and as a mode of people interacting. And now... But think about it this way too, like, we used to interact like in kind of ways that are kind of mushy, you know, you would make a weird joke and the person wouldn't react the way, so you wouldn't make that joke again, or you would find that somebody has the same sense of humor. And like, what relationships get reduced to like on line, and forgive me because I'm not on these things,
现在正在被投射出来。没错。作为一种生活方式，也作为人们互动的一种方式。现在……但换个角度想想，我们以前的互动方式带点儿糊里糊涂的劲儿，你知道的，你会开个奇怪的玩笑，而对方的反应不对劲，所以你以后就不会再开那个玩笑了，或者你会发现有人和你有相同的幽默感。而网上的关系被简化成了什么样，请原谅我，因为我不用这些东西，
but this is my kind of cynical attitude towards it is like we like the same band and so it hooks us up and everything. And that's essentially like the character I was playing could interact with people like that on this very much like we both like this band, let's stand here and talk about it. And like that's the way the thing works too.
但这只是我对它的一种愤世嫉俗的态度，就像我们喜欢同一支乐队，所以它把我们联系在一起，诸如此类。这本质上就像我扮演的角色可以和人们以这种方式互动，在这个非常像我们都喜欢这个乐队的层面上，让我们站在这里聊聊。这东西的运作方式也是这样的。
It recommends this person to you or if you're dating, it recommends this person to you. And it just takes out the squishy humanness that we have in our lives outside of the internet. Yeah, for sure. However, I mean, you speak, you've spoken before, you've spoken already in this episode about your, you know, not to belittle it, to be honest,
它向你推荐这个人，或者如果你在约会，它向你推荐这个人。它只是剥离了我们在互联网之外的生活中拥有的那种黏糊糊的人性。是的，当然。然而，我的意思是，你讲过，你在这个节目中已经讲过了关于你自己的，你知道的，并不是要贬低它，老实说，
it's charming, your self-effacing, sort of that you're comfortable with yourself, and I get it, we all are, but I feel like these social media things are meant to be a tool to actually help folks that don't. That's true, and probably it does. Yeah, that wouldn't get out to a bar and start. So I'm wondering if, you know.
它很迷人，你的自嘲，某种程度上你对自己很自在，我明白，我们都是这样，但我觉得这些社交媒体东西本来就是一种工具，实际上是为了帮助那些不自在的人。确实如此，可能也确实有帮助。对，那些不会去酒吧主动搭讪的人。所以我在想，你知道。
I'm sure you're right. I truly know nothing about this because I'm not on it. I haven't had the experience of being on it. No, no, no. Jason, I think that there is, that's what it's sold as. And I think that in its best version, were people actually looking to do that and it wasn't used as a way to enrich people,
我确信你是对的。我对这个真的完全不了解，因为我没玩过。我没有过玩这个的体验。不，不，不。杰森，我认为，这就是它被推销的方式。而且我认为，在它最好的版本里，如果人们真的是为了那个目的，而不是把它作为一种让人致富的手段，
then that's what it would do. Unfortunately, what has become is it's designed to keep you engaged to sell ads. Now, what it's done is it's designed to keep you opening the app. Here he comes. So that your eyeballs will be exposed to advertisers. We all need advertisers.
那它就会起到那样的作用。不幸的是，它现在变成了一个旨在让你沉迷并靠卖广告赚钱的东西。现在，它的设计目的就是让你不断打开这个App。他来了。好让广告商能接触到你们的眼球。我们都需要广告商。
I'm not, but it keeps us all employed. Of course. That is its design. And it's not to keep people engaged. And I think that there was a time that maybe that was the idea. And maybe that's what the social, when it was called The Facebook was about, but unfortunately what it has become is become this thing that's become incredibly divisive
我不是，但它让我们所有人都有饭吃。当然。这就是它的设计目的。它不是为了让人们真正参与其中。我想曾经有一段时间，这或许就是它的初衷。也许这就是当社交软件还叫The Facebook时的意义所在，但不幸的是，它后来变成了这样一个极具分裂性的东西，
and all it's done is reinforced, instead of celebrating the similarities, it's reinforced the differences between people. It's had the opposite effect. It's stunning. All these kinds of things. We're talking, you know, we talk about inclusion, so all these things that all they've done
它所做的一切，不是去赞美彼此的相似之处，而是在不断强化人与人之间的差异。它起到了完全相反的效果。这太惊人了。所有这些类似的事情。我们正在谈论，你知道的，我们谈论包容性，所以所有这些事情，它们所做的一切
is help create these many barriers between us all and said, I'm this and I'm this and I'm this and you're that. And we've created more division, I think. I don't know. Yeah, that's my perspective. But my perspective is really as an outsider because I haven't been on it.
就是帮我们在彼此之间竖起层层壁垒，并宣称：我是这样的，我是那样的，而你是另一种人。我认为，我们制造了更多的分裂。我不知道。好吧，这是我的视角。但我的视角其实是一个局外人的视角，因为我没玩过。
But yeah, like that, it creates isolation, sectarianism, all this stuff. Wait, are you on social media? No, no, no. I'm kidding. Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah, I'm actually live tweeting this whole thing. Like, going great.
但对，就像那样，它会造成孤立、宗派主义，诸如此类的一切。等等，你玩社交媒体吗？不，不，不。我开玩笑的。噢，对，对。对，我其实正在对整场活动进行现场直播。感觉棒极了。
Sean said social network is so good. Um. Um. Um. Thumbs up. Yeah. Now, studying anthropology and social psychology in college, yes?
肖恩说社交网络太棒了。嗯。嗯。嗯。竖起大拇指。对。对了，你在大学里学的是人类学和社会心理学，对吧？
Yeah, yes. Now, why did you study that when you knew you wanted to do what you're doing now? Or did you do it at the same time? Yeah, no, I was like, I went to college for 18 years before I got my degree, because I would like go to a semester and then take off and work, you know, and then go back.
对，没错。那么，既然你当时就知道自己想做现在这份工作，为什么还要学这个呢？还是说你是同时进行的？对，没有，我当时是这样的：我上了18年大学才拿到学位，因为我会去读一个学期，然后休学去工作，你知道的，接着又回去读。
And so I got my degree during the pandemic finally. Oh, you're serious? It took you 18 years to get it? Yeah, exactly, it took me 18 years, yeah, exactly. No way. Way, yeah, like the second 18 years of my life, yeah, from 18 to 36. And I chose anthropology,
所以我终于在大流行期间拿到了学位。噢，你是认真的？你花了18年才拿到学位？对，没错，我花了18年，哈哈，真的。不会吧。真的，就像我人生的第二个18年一样，对，从18岁到36岁。我选择人类学，
because that was my wife's degree. She graduated like many, many years before. So that was her degree, and I just wanted to have something to talk about with her. That's cool. Yeah, because I knew I wanted, because I- Because otherwise it's silence. I wanted to be in the arts.
因为那是毛发学……不对，那是海伦……是因为那是我妻子的专业。她毕业比我早很多很多年。所以那是她的专业，我只是想找点话题和她聊。挺酷的。对，因为我知道我想……因为否则的话那就是一片沉默。我想从事艺术工作。
Yeah, otherwise she would not talk to me. Would you define anthropology for me? Yeah, anthropology is like the study of, and I'm using quotes, the other, it's the study of other cultures, the study of other people. What you learn from it is that your culture is not superior to another culture,
对，否则她根本不会跟我说话。你能为我定义一下人类学吗？对，人类学有点像是研究——我这里用引号——“他者”，它是对其他文化的研究，对其他人群的研究。你从中学到的是，你的文化并不比另一种文化更优越，
even if that culture is like, let's say, more poor or something. You learn to kind of view cultures as their own value to the effect that they have on each other. So an anthropologist would go to study, famously go to Samoan village, Margaret Mead is a famous anthropologist, go to a Samoan village and live with them
即使那种文化，比方说，更贫穷一些。你会学会用一种客观的眼光去看待各种文化自身的价值，以及它们对彼此产生的影响。所以人类学家会去进行研究，最著名的就是去萨摩亚村庄，玛格丽特·米德是一位著名的人类学家，她去了一个萨摩亚村庄和他们生活在一起，
and study their ways and everything. I literally asked somebody last night who has a master in anthropology, I asked her to define it. Same question last night. She said something very similar, and I said, well, what is the difference between that and sociology? And she said that sociology is much more data-driven.
研究他们的生活方式和一切。我昨晚刚问过一个拥有人类学硕士学位的人，我让她给它下个定义。昨晚也是这个问题。她说了非常相似的话，然后我问她，那这和社会学有什么区别呢？她说社会学更加注重数据驱动。
Is that fair? Yeah, yeah, my dad's PhD is social psychology, and so he was studying basically human behavior irrespective of culture. It was about people interacting with each other. Anthropology really focuses on cultures. Right, right, right. Wow, so, and you got your bachelor's or master's?
这样说公平吗？对，对，我父亲的博士学位是社会心理学的，所以他研究的基本上是抛开文化的人类行为。这关乎人与人之间的互动。人类学则真正专注于文化。对，对，对。哇，所以，你拿的是学士学位还是硕士学位？
I got my bachelor's degree. Yeah. That's amazing. Bachelor's degree and then your dad's got a PhD. Yeah. This is an accomplished family. Jay, what'd you learn on the set of Ned and Stacey? I remember you did it on that episode. Yeah.
我拿的是学士学位。太棒了。学士学位，然后你父亲拥有博士学位。这真是一个学霸家庭。杰伊，你在《奈德和史黛西》片场学到了什么？我记得你拍那一集时做过。
I learned how to scoop a bagel, you know? That's where I started really cutting the carbs. So Jesse, but first of all, by the time you're 65, you get your master's. But second, you, that's really funny. In your studies, what is the one kind of culture that you found the most fascinating or actually interacted with or whatever?
我学会了怎么把贝果面包掏空，你知道吗？那就是我真正开始控制碳水化合物的起点。所以杰西，首先，等你65岁的时候，你就能拿到硕士学位了。但其次，你——这真的太好笑了。在你的研究中，你发现哪一种文化最让你着迷，或者你真正接触过的文化是哪一种？
Best and least, and least, to be fair. The least fascinating culture. Okay, the most boring culture, you guys, is I'm doing top 10 worst cultures. I would love if you got on Instagram just so you could start posting things like the worst cultures. Yeah, and this one is boring but also stupid.
说出最好的和最差的，最差的。最不让人着迷的文化。好吧，最无聊的文化，各位，我正在盘点十大最差文化。如果你能在Instagram上开个号，专门开始发类似“最差文化”这样的内容，我真的会很高兴。对，这个既无聊又愚蠢。
So, okay, this one, no, I mean, well, I kind of like, I did my like ethnography, which is like, you know, your big thesis. I did it on this like, this restaurant in Chelsea that was like the last remaining authentic Latin American restaurant because everything else had been, you know, gentrified away. And this place was, but it was so, it was kind of a cheat because it was like down the block. And I got to eat there while I was doing my field research, you know
所以，好吧，这个，不，我是说，我有点像是，我做了我的民族志研究，也就是你的那种大型毕业论文。我的研究对象是切尔西区的一家餐厅，那是最后一家仅存的地道拉丁美洲餐厅，因为其他所有店都已经被中产阶级化给吞噬了。这家店是，但它有点作弊，因为它就在街区尽头。我做田野调查的时候还能顺便在那儿吃饭，你知道的。
But it was it was really interesting to see how this place was trying to survive against, you know Yeah, you do restaurants. I thought it was like cultures across the world. Like you're like it is this was cultural Oh, okay, my wife my wife went to Nicaragua restaurant review dude No, and actually what restaurant was it we can always cut it out. I was called Restaurant review, dude? Yeah, no. It's not a restaurant. Yeah, no. And actually we published... Wait, what restaurant was it? We can always cut it out. It was called La Taza de Oro.
但看到这家店如何在……中努力求生存，真的很有趣。对，你做的是餐馆研究。我以为是世界各地的文化。就像你觉得这就是文化。噢，好吧，我妻子去过尼加拉瓜餐馆评论老兄。不，其实到底是什么餐馆？我们总可以把它剪掉。刚才叫餐馆评论老兄吗？对，没有。那不是个餐馆。对，没有。其实我们发表了……等等，那是哪家餐馆？我们随时可以剪掉。它叫拉塔萨德奥罗（La Taza de Oro）。
It's not there anymore. Yeah. We published the thesis actually to Yelp, so it was interesting to get to publish. Oh, wow. No, no, no, I'm kidding. Not every student gets their work published, but for me, it went, you know, it was in the bottom. When I got my PhD from food porn on Instagram.
它现在已经不在了。对。我们其实把这篇论文发表到了Yelp上，所以能发表出来挺有意思的。噢，哇。不，不，不，我开玩笑的。不是每个学生的成果都能发表，但对我和我来说，它沉入了……当我在Instagram上从美食色情片里拿到博士学位的时候。
Fucking. All right. Now, what about, let's talk about, what about, was, was Squid and the Whale the thing that, that sort of launched you a bit? No, I was in a movie before that when I was like 18. Roger Dodger? Yeah, Roger Dodger, right out of high school, yeah. And it was like the difference
他妈的。好了。那么，我们来谈谈，《鱿鱼和鲸》是不是那部让你稍微有点起步的作品？没有，我在此之前演过一部电影，当时我大概18岁。罗杰·道格者？对，《罗杰·道格者》，刚高中毕业，对。这简直就是
between having an acting career or not. It was literally a difference, because I was supposed to go to college that year, and my dad, I pled with him. I was like, please just read the script, it's so good. And my dad read it and said, okay, you could take off a semester and do this movie. And the movie was like not a hit,
拥有演艺生涯与否的区别。这真的是个转折点，因为我本打算那年去上大学，而我父亲，我苦求他。我跟他说：求求你读一下这个剧本，它太棒了。我爸读完后说：好吧，你可以休学一个学期去拍这部电影。这部电影虽说不上是个轰动的大热门，
but it was like popular amongst people who like movies. And then that meant, again, God bless Wikipedia, that meant no NYU for you, but the new school when you were done with it, yes? Yes, oh my God. Which paragraph are you up to? I've been up for at least an hour and a half. Are you into, is that early career in school or are you on personal info?
但它在喜欢电影的人中间挺受欢迎的。这意味着，再次感谢维基百科，这意味着你无缘纽约大学，但毕业后去了新学院，对吧？对，天哪。你念到哪一段了？我已经醒了至少一个半小时了。你是看到早期演艺生涯和学校那部分，还是看到个人隐私信息了？
I think it's either controversies. Because sometimes they mix it up, you know what I mean? Like sometimes they... I think it's under cancellation. All right, so then, so you do Roger Dodger and you feel... Wait, can I just say this? Sorry to get it. Can I just say, it is a real, I may have mentioned this before, but it is a real testament to who you are in this world
我觉得要麽是争议部分。因为他们有时候会把内容搞混，你知道我的意思吗？就像有时候他们会……我觉得是在被取消风波那一栏。好吧，所以，你演了《罗杰·道格者》，然后你觉得……等等，我能说这个吗？抱歉打断一下。我能说吗，这真的是一个很好的证明，证明了你在当今世界上的地位，
when your filmography has its own page on Wikipedia. Have you ever noticed that? Oh yeah. What does that mean? That is something else. Well, he's going to somebody's and they have filmography and then goes, and there's a link. Oh, it transfers you?
当你的电影作品年表在维基百科上有它自己专属的页面时。你注意过这个吗？噢，对。那意味着什么？那绝对是破天荒头一遭。好吧，他正看着某个人的资料，上面有电影作品年表，然后点击，就会出现一个链接。噢，它会跳转？
It transfers, there's a link. I have seen that before, yeah. Because it has its own page. Oh, is that what's happening here? That is the highest of thought. That is the goal, that is the goal. Yeah, you know you've made it when you have to transfer. So there's a feeling that is very tangible,
它会跳转，有一个链接。我以前见过，对。因为它有单独的页面。噢，这就是这里发生的事吗？这可是最高赞誉了。这就是终极目标，这就是终极目标。对，你知道你成功了，当你的名字需要跳转页面的时候。所以那种感觉是非常真切的，
that it's like, oh, I think I might be able to make a career out of this, based on this sort of new found access and inclusion, yes? Exactly, exactly. And like right after that movie, I got like offered another movie and it was to pay scale. It was like a movie, I don't think it ever got made.
就好像是：噢，我觉得我或许能靠这个吃这碗饭了。基于这种新获得的认可和接纳，对吗？没错，没错。就像拍完那部电影后不久，我又接到了一部电影的邀约，而且是按最低演员工会标准（pay scale）付酬的。那是一部，我觉得它后来根本没拍成。
It was probably like a $50,000 budget. But I remember going to my dad and like, I could get jobs, like I could literally just get jobs. Cause before that, you know, I was auditioning for commercials and anything that I could possibly get an audition for and you know, understudies and plays and stuff like that so it felt like oh I can literally make a career and a possible living from this.
预算可能也就5万美元左右。但我记得我去找我爸说：我能接到工作了，我真的能接到工作了。因为在此之前，你知道的，我一直在为商业广告试镜，只要能弄到试镜机会的我都去，还有戏剧里的替补演员之类的工作，所以当时的感觉是：噢，我真的可以靠这个开启职业生涯，并以此谋生。
Right and then what was the next big job? Was it Squid and the Whale? Yeah actually no right before that I did this movie Cursed with it was dimension and it was dimension so it was run by Bob Weinstein and and this guy would, it was crazy, this guy, basically it was a Wes Craven directed movie, and Bob Weinstein would just constantly scrap everything we'd done to the point where we shot, it was supposed to be a 55 day shoot, we shot 125 days,
对，那接下来的大工作是什么？是《鱿鱼和鲸》吗？对，其实不是，在那之前我拍了一部电影叫《灵异村》，那是帝门影业的。那是帝门影业的项目，所以是由鲍勃·韦恩斯坦掌管的，这家伙，这太疯狂了，这家伙，基本上那是一部由韦斯·克雷文导演的电影，而鲍勃·韦恩斯坦会不断地把你拍过的所有东西全部推翻重来，严重到原本计划拍55天的戏，我们最后拍了125天，
because this guy, Bob Weinstein, who's not like, you know, a writer, you know, would just decide that he wanted to change everything in the script, and it was crazy, it was crazy, and fascinating to work with that man. I wonder what he's up to right now. I think we know what his brother's doing, but wonder what father's doing.
因为这家伙——鲍勃·韦恩斯坦，他可不是什么编剧——总是随心所欲地想要改动剧本里的所有内容，这太疯狂了，和那种人共事既疯狂又迷人。我想知道他现在在干什么。我想我们都知道他兄弟在干什么，不过好奇他父亲在干什么。
Probably his neck in lawsuits. No, I'm kidding. No, I'm kidding. What he's up to. I wanted to turn down the movie and he called me in for a meeting and he's threatened my career. And then he said, at the end, as I was leaving,
可能官司缠身吧。不，我开玩笑的。不，我开玩笑的。看看他在忙什么。我当时想拒绝那部电影，他叫我去开会，还威胁了我的职业生涯。然后他说，在我临走的时候，
he said, I know where you live. I said, what? Jesus Christ. And I was like are you kidding? And he was like no no no she told me. His casting director. He goes no no no she told me where you live. Oh these guys.
他说：我知道你住哪。我说：什么？天哪！我当时想：你在开玩笑吧？他说：不，不，不，她告诉我的。他的选角导演。他说：不，不，不，她告诉我你住哪的。噢，这群家伙。
Wow. What a duo. I know. Unbelievable. When all this stuff came out with the brother I was just like oh yeah I've been telling this story forever and people sometimes can't believe it. It sounds so shocking and then of course my story was like nothing compared to. Right, yeah, cute. Yeah, yeah.
哇。真是绝配啊。我知道。难以置信。当关于他兄弟的那些丑闻曝光的时候，我当时就想：噢，对，我讲这个故事讲了无数遍了，人们有时根本不相信。听起来太令人震惊了，当然，跟那些比起来，我的故事简直不值一提。对，没错，真可爱。对，对。
Yeah, it's so cute. All right, so now. Yeah, you're like, who knew? It's just like a fun banter for a podcast. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah, not like... So now we're to Squid and the Whale
对，太可爱了。好吧，那么现在。对，你就像是在说：谁能想到呢？这就像是播客里的一段有趣闲聊。对，没错。没错。对，不像……所以现在我们来到《鱿鱼和鲸》
with the great Laura Linney, the incredible Noah Baumbach. Did you, and Jeff Daniels, did you learn a great deal from Mr. Baumbach there with the writing and the directing? Did that plant an early seed for you? Well, it's just like he was writing just stuff that amused him, and so that was the trick. It's like, oh yeah, you can write the things that you like
合作了伟大的劳拉·琳妮，不可思议的诺亚·鲍姆巴赫。你和杰夫·丹尼尔斯，你们从鲍姆巴赫先生身上学到了很多关于编剧和导演的知识吗？这为你种下了早期的种子吗？嗯，就是他写的东西只是为了取悦他自己，这就是诀窍所在。这就好比：噢，对，你可以写你喜欢的东西，
and it'll translate, hopefully. And the other main thing I learned was the trick. It's like, oh yeah, you can write the things that you like and it'll translate, you know, hopefully. And the other main thing I learned was from Lauren. I don't know if she ever did this to you, probably. But she had a slap me in the movie. Has she slapped you? Probably. Probably, yeah. Okay, so this is what she told me.
而且它会产生共鸣，希望如此。我学到的另一个主要诀窍是。这就好比：噢，对，你可以写你喜欢的东西，而且它会产生共鸣，你知道的，希望如此。我学到的另一个主要诀窍是从劳拉那儿学来的。我不知道她有没有对你这么做过，大概率有吧。她在电影里扇了我一巴掌。她扇过你吗？大概吧。大概吧，对。好吧，这就是她对我说的话。
Right before she slapped me, she said, do you know what the trick is to slap somebody in a movie? And I was like, no, please tell me. Thank you, tell me. She just whacked you, surprise. Yeah, she goes, you look the person in the eye and then you hit them with your hand. And I was like, oh, that's not a trick at all.
就在她扇我巴掌之前，她说：你知道在电影里扇别人巴掌的诀窍是什么吗？我说：不知道，请告诉我。谢谢，告诉我吧。她直接一巴掌呼过来，搞突袭。对，她说：你看着那个人的眼睛，然后用手打过去。我说：噢，这根本不是什么诀窍啊。
And so she just spent the night slapping me. And that was the trick. And then in this movie I made with Kieran, I said, you know, I have to slap him at the end of the movie and it's this big thing at the end of the movie. And I told him, do you know the trick? I learned this from the great Laura Linney and I was like, you just, I slap you really hard.
然后她那一整晚都在扇我巴掌。这就是诀窍。后来在我跟基兰合作的那部电影里，我说：你知道的，我在电影结尾得扇他一巴掌，这是电影结尾的一个大场面。我告诉他：你知道诀窍吗？这是我从伟大的劳拉·琳妮那儿学来的，我说：你只要……我狠狠地扇了你一巴掌。
And that was- You just gotta make sure you have eye contact. Yeah, exactly, make eye contact. Yeah. Which doesn't mitigate the feeling at all. No, it doesn't. It makes it more personal. If anything, it makes it worse.
那就是——你只需要确保有眼神交流。对，没错，进行眼神交流。但这根本无法减轻那种感觉。不，并没有。这让它变得更私人了。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是它让情况更糟糕了。
Exactly. Yes, that's true. I've had to do some slaps and I've found that you just have to change the timing of it on every single take so that you get that genuine surprise. You know? Oh, that's interesting. Which is not really fair to the person receiving the slap,
没错。是的，确实如此。我也拍过一些挨耳光的戏，我发现你必须在每一次镜头拍摄时改变它的时机，这样才能获得那种真正的惊讶感。你知道吗？噢，这很有趣。这对挨耳光的人来说其实不太公平，
but it's great for the audience. On Will and Grace, if we were to slap somebody, Jimmy Burrows would clap off screen. Wait, what? Time it to our face. Really? Oh, but you were not actually near them? Like not hitting them?
但对观众来说效果绝佳。在《威尔和格蕾丝》里，如果我们必须扇别人耳光，吉米·伯罗斯会在镜头外拍手。等等，什么？配合我们的脸部动作。真的吗？噢，但你其实没有靠近他们？就比如没有真的打上去？
You would fake the slap. You would go just in front of their face, but he would time it and he would just clap. Oh, that's interesting. So that the audience would hear that it wasn't a miss. Yes, that's right. The great Jimmy Burroughs. By the way, and that's the sound
你会假装打。你会把手挥到他们脸前，但他会算准时机，然后拍手。噢，那很有趣。这样观众就会听到声音，觉得没有打空。是的，没。伟大的吉米·伯罗斯。顺便说一句，那就是他们最终保留在剧中的声音。噢，哇。
that they would keep in the show. Oh, wow. JB, do you remember season one of Arrested Development? I was in a wheelchair and I was wearing a hospital gown and you were leaning down in front of me. It was the end of an episode and you were leaning down in front of me and as you leaned down I slapped you in the face. It was not in the script.
JB，你还记得《发展受阻》第一季吗？我当时坐在轮椅上，穿着病号服，你弯腰凑到我面前。那是一集的结尾，你弯腰凑到我面前，就在你弯下腰的时候，我扇了你一巴掌。剧本里根本没有这一出。
It was apropos of nothing. I slapped you and you looked at me and my bare leg was showing because I was wearing a hospital gown and as you got up you slapped the inside of my legs so much As hard as I could hard as I walk and in the show I go Oh, just cuz it really it really happened you fucking killed me right and it was safe to do that because you're in a wheelchair You can't possibly get up and run after my character couldn't get up and run after him so he knew the character. Yeah Was it it was not it was happened on one take In the show and that's the one they use.
这完全是即兴的。我扇了你一巴掌，你看着我，因为我穿着病号服，所以我光溜溜的大腿露了出来，当你站起来的时候，你狠狠地拍了我大腿内侧，狠狠地，用尽全力，用尽全力，剧本里我喊道：噢！就因为这真的、真的发生了，你把我整惨了，对吧，而且这样做很安全，因为你坐在轮椅上，你根本不可能站起来追我。我的角色不可能站起来追他，所以他很清楚这个角色。对。这是一次过完成的吗？在剧中就是用的那一条。
And I learned on the tour, the smartless tour, that Jason will just, I've never had somebody do this in my entire life, he would just walk up to me and slap me on my face. Yeah. Just sort of like a... Just make eye contact? Hey buddy. I love the way you act like you're just as surprised as everybody, Jason.
我在巡演——也就是smartless巡演——上学到了一点，杰森会直接……我这辈子从来没见过有人这样做，他会直接朝我走过来，然后狠狠地扇我脸。对。就像这样……只要进行眼神交流？嘿，老兄。杰森，我喜欢你假装自己和大家一样惊讶的样子。
You just went, yeah, I know, I learned that. Isn't that crazy? Yeah, like I just do that. Like I do it all the time. It's a love tap, y'all. Well, it's pretty hard. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
你当时就说：对，我懂，我是从那儿学来的。这难道不疯狂吗？对，就像我就会这么做。就像我经常这么做。这只是爱的抚摸，各位。好吧，下手挺狠的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。
Now, speaking of magic, the magic of movies, let's get to Now You See Me. So there was a lot of magic in that, or illusions, sorry Will, illusions. No worries, yeah, sure. I would imagine you did a little bit of training for that. Have you retained any magical talents? Like, do you have a go-to card trick?
说到魔术，电影的魔术，让我们来聊聊《惊天魔盗团》。所以里面有很多魔术，或者说幻术，抱歉威尔，是幻术。没事，对，当然。我猜你为此做了一些训练吧？你还保留了什么魔术天赋吗？比如，你有什么拿手的纸牌把戏吗？
I do, I do, and it's weird weird because I have like muscle memory from it. We just finished doing the third movie like a month ago and I just do the same one trick I know. And for audiences who are paying attention, they'll realize that the greatest magician in the world knows one trick. Yeah? Yeah. I just repurposed the one thing I learned.
我有，我有，而且很诡异，因为我对此有肌肉记忆。我们大概在一个月前刚拍完第三部电影，而我只会变我知道的那个唯一的魔术。对于那些聚精会神的观众来说，他们会发现全世界最伟大的魔术师只会变一个魔术。对吧？对。我只是把我学过的唯一一招重新包装了一下。
Yeah. In a different outfit. Someone was doing a magic thing at something I was at last week and I just thought that, like, and he did a series of magical tricks, as they do, before they're done with their set. And by the time you get to like the third trick, you know your mind's gonna be blown. You know you're gonna be like,
对。换了一套衣服。上周我参加某个活动时，有人在表演魔术，我当时就在想，他表演了一系列魔术，就像他们通常做的那样，在表演结束之前。当你看到第三个魔术的时候，你知道你的大脑肯定会被震撼到。你知道你当时会觉得：
oh my God, how do you do that? And you just sort of like click into a gear of like, all right, let's see it. Here comes another sort of mind-bending wow. And what I thought was, what would really be impressive at this point is to now tell us how you did it. Because I know I'm going to be shocked.
噢，天哪，你是怎么做到的？然后你就会进入一种状态，心想：好吧，让我们拭目以待吧。又一个颠覆认知的大招要来了。而我当时的想法是，在这个时候，最令人印象深刻的其实是告诉我们你是怎么做到的。因为我知道我会被震撼。
What would be really impressive is to see how you're doing this stuff, how you trained yourself and taught yourself to hide all these things that I didn't see. So when is magic gonna change into that, perhaps? God, when are you gonna enjoy life? When? When will you enjoy anything?
最令人印象深刻的，其实是看看你是怎么变这些把戏的，你是如何训练自己并学会把那些我没看见的机关全都藏起来的。所以魔术什么时候才会变成那样呢？天哪，你什么时候才能享受生活？什么时候？你什么时候才能享受任何东西？
That's the magic. That's the magic. My heart is breaking from you. I just had therapy, but when we're done, I'm gonna call him and I'm gonna bring you in, JB. Jump on with Terry. Fuck, man. Oh, God, my heart.
这就是魔术。这就是魔术。我为你感到心碎。我刚做完心理治疗，但等我们结束之后，我要打电话给他，把你带过去，JB。去找特里聊聊吧。妈的，老天。噢，天哪，我的心。
I wanna- Please just see a Terry. I wanna hug you. You wonder if you see the same Terry I used to? I really wanna hug you right now. and JB jump on with Terry, fuck man, oh God, my heart. I want to drive a Terry. I want to hug you. I wonder if you see the same Terry I used to. I really want to hug you right now. I feel just, there's just zero inner. You can't experience wonder. I'll take it, I'll take a hug anytime or slab.
我想要——求求你去看个特里吧。我想给你一个拥抱。你在想你看到的特里是不是跟我以前看的是同一个？我现在真的很想给你一个拥抱。我感觉，内心的火花完全为零。你无法体验到惊奇感。我接受，我随时接受一个拥抱或者一巴掌。
But Jason, there is this show on TV, it was called like Breaking the Magician's Code or something like that. It's like Magic's Biggest Secrets or something like that. And's like magic's biggest secrets or something like that. And they did that. They revealed all those big tricks. Oh, they did. How they did it, I thought was fascinating.
但是杰森，电视上有个节目，好像叫《解密魔术师》之类的。类似《魔术最大的秘密》之类的。类似魔术最大的秘密什么的。他们就是这么干的。他们揭秘了所有那些大型魔术。噢，他们确实这么干了。他们是怎么做到的，我觉得非常迷人。
I wanna see that. I'll look at that. And then what are you left with? Then I'll just start reading ingredients on food packaging, just knowing what's on the inside. There's tons of stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Read credits on movies.
我想看那个。我会去看看的。然后你还剩下什么？那我只会开始阅读食品包装上的配料表，一眼就能看出里面有什么。里面有一大堆东西呢。对，对，对。阅读电影片尾字幕。
You're gonna peek behind every curtain. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, when you hear about these, like when you hear how these magicians have done the trick though, sometimes it's far more impressive than the trick because the kind of work that went into making something look seamless is like, you know, shocking.
你会去掀开每一个幕布偷看。对，对，对。你知道的，当你听到这些……不过当你听到这些魔术师是如何破解魔术的时候，有时甚至比魔术本身还要震撼，因为为了让某个东西看起来天衣无缝而付出的那些努力，你知道的，太惊人了。
Right, right, right, right. All right, talk to me about your move into directing, why that happened and when it happened, was it simply a result of you arriving at a place in your career where you could say, hey, I want to now direct, and you had the sort of industry capital in order to say that, or did it happen more organically than that?
对，对，对，对。好吧，跟我聊聊你向导演的转型，为什么会发生以及是什么时候发生的，这仅仅是因为你的职业生涯达到了这样一个阶段：你可以说，嘿，我现在想当导演了，并且你拥有了说出这句话所需的行业资本，还是说这个过程比这更加顺其自然？
No, I basically- In other words, had you wanted to do it for a long, long time and then? No, I basically- In other words, had you wanted to do it for a long, long time and then- No, I've always just wanted to write plays and then my last play, which was like 2019, just like wasn't received well and I was like kind of really, yeah, like kind of heartbroken or whatever.
不，我基本上——换句话说，你是不是想当导演已经很久很久了，然后？不，我基本上——换句话说，你是不是想当导演已经很久很久了，然后？不，我一直只想写戏剧，然后我的最后一部剧，大概是2019年的那部，反响不太好，我当时就觉得，真的，心碎欲绝之类的。
Like the play wasn't received well. And I mean, the actors were amazing in it, but the play wasn't received well. And like, so I just was like, I have to try something else. I just made me feel bad. And there was like scrutiny in a way that felt like mean-spirited in a way just was like, I have to try something else. It just made me feel bad. And there was scrutiny in a way that felt mean-spirited in a way that was like, oh, this is industry can be. I mean, movies can also be quite cool.
就像那部剧反响不好一样。我的意思是，里面的演员棒极了，但剧本身反响不好。所以我就觉得：我得尝试点别的。这让我感觉很糟糕。而且那种审视让人感觉带着一种恶意的挑剔，当时就觉得：我必须尝试点别的。这让我感觉很糟糕。而且那种审视让人感觉带着一种恶意的挑剔，就觉得：噢，这个行业就是这样。我的意思是，电影其实也挺酷的。
But just something about theater because it's such a small community. I don't know, it just, anyway. So I just thought, let me try to, I'll do a movie next. Yeah, no, but I love writing plays more than anything. But I just thought maybe I should do a movie. Because yeah, and the thing you said about Clout, that like, I did, I guess, feel not so much Clout,
但戏剧总有些独特之处，因为它是个这么小的圈子。我不知道，总之……所以我就想，让我试一试吧，我下一部作品拍电影。对，不，但我最喜欢的还是写戏剧。不过我只是觉得也许我应该拍部电影。因为，对，你刚才说的关于影响力的事，我当时确实，感觉与其说是影响力，
but more like, oh, I feel like I've been around it enough to kind of have an understanding of what to do. I know that sounds so lame, like I didn't go to film school, but I just felt like I've been on sets that have been great and I've been on sets that didn't work and I've been on sets that were terrible sets but made great movies and vice versa. I felt like, oh no, I think I know what to do
不如说是：噢，我觉得我在这行待得够久了，对该怎么做有了一定理解。我知道这听起来很逊，好像我没上过电影学校一样，但我就是觉得，我待过很棒的片场，也待过搞砸了的片场，还待过剧组很烂但拍出了伟大电影的片场，反之亦然。我觉得：噢，不，我想我知道该怎么做了，
if I can write something that is like tailored to my limited skill set. There's nothing wrong, yeah, you obviously, you're around it, you pick up on it, and it makes sense that you would want to sort of take agency and kind of do it yourself. And Sean last week, watching his chef open tuna cans, and finally he was like,
如果我能写出一个量身定制、适合我那有限技能的剧本的话。这没什么不对的，对吧，你显然身处其中，耳濡目染，你想掌握主动权并亲自尝试，这完全合情合理。肖恩上周看着他的主厨打开金枪鱼罐头，最后他说：
I'm gonna open a tuna can. It's not dissimilar, you know what I mean? I can pinch the top on it and make the water come out. Or at least let me try it. I can eat the Hershey's syrup out of the bottle. You know what I mean? Watch me squirt it. Of course.
我要自己开个金枪鱼罐头。这其实没多大区别，你知道我的意思吗？我可以捏住盖子顶部把水挤出来。或者至少让我试试。我可以从瓶子里挤出好时巧克力酱吃。你知道我的意思吗？看着我把它挤出来。当然。
And I think in Sean's case it is cloud. I think you feel you've worked up to this. And I think the industry recognizes that you can open up stuff. I didn't want to embarrass anybody. Yeah. No, and it's good that you're finally in a place where you feel like, yes, I can do that,
而且我认为对肖恩来说，这确实是影响力。我觉得你觉得自己已经奋斗到了这个地步。并且我认为业内也认可你有能力去驾驭一些东西。我可不想让任何人难堪。对，很好，你能终于走到这一步，觉得自己可以做到，
and yes, I'm not going to get. It's really good. Thank you. Yeah, thank you, Mr. Einstein. So wait, so you were feeling a little in your fee-fees about getting the bad reviews basically on the play, and then you thought you'd go for something with even higher exposure directing a film
而且不会被……这真的很好。谢谢。对，谢谢你，爱因斯坦先生。所以等等，所以你当时因为这部剧得到了差评而感到有点小情绪，然后你决定挑战更高曝光率的事情——执导一部电影，
where you would, opening yourself up to even more spread audience. Yeah, I was very brave of you. You went the other way. Oh, thanks. I mean, I don't know. Yeah, but I guess I'm used to scrutiny. I mean, I'm used to scrutiny and I care about it so much,
这会让你把自己暴露在更广泛的观众面前。对，你可真勇敢。你偏要反其道而行之。噢，谢谢。我是说，我不知道。对，但我想我已经习惯了审视。我是说，我习惯了审视，而且我在事情发生时会非常在乎它，
I guess while it's happening, and then literally not the next day. I just, you know, I don't want to be governed. Laura Linney said the greatest thing, that I actually didn't hear her say, but my dad heard her on Charlie Rose talk about this 20 years ago, but they asked, or he asked her, do you read reviews?
然后到了第二天，字面意义上就完全不在乎了。我只是，你知道的，我不想被它左右。劳拉·琳妮说过一句最棒的话，虽然我其实没有亲耳听到她这么说，但我爸20年前在查理·罗斯的节目上听到她谈过这个，当时别人问她——或者说他问她：你读评论吗？
And she says, no, because I don't want somebody else to tell me how to do my job. And my dad was telling me this, because I'm such a, I was like a self-conscious person. He said, your colleague who you were in that movie with, this is how she views it. And it did really change my perspective. That's interesting.
她说：不读，因为我不想让别人来教我怎么做我的工作。我爸把这个讲给我听，因为我曾经是个非常自我意识过剩的人。他说：你在那部电影里合作的同行，她是这么看待这件事的。这确实改变了我的视角。很有意思。
Yeah. It is a really odd concept. I totally understand the aggregate of them all, right? So Rotten Tomatoes, where they put them all, and then there's sort of like a consensus. Does this work for the general public, I suppose, since you're making a public effort with your art? But specific reviewers, their specific take
这确实是一个非常奇特的观念。我完全理解它们汇总在一起的意义，对吧？比如烂番茄网站，他们把所有评论汇总起来，然后形成某种共识。它是否适合普通大众，我想是的，既然你是在用你的艺术进行公众创作的话？但特定的评论家，他们针对
on how it affected them as an individual, well, we're not making things for one individual, we're making things for a whole public, and so it's not going to work for some people and that doesn't mean that it's broken. But I also saw, like, well, I think you're right about the aggregate thing, but at the same time, have there been films or pieces or music that have gotten bad reviews that you really like?
这部作品如何作为一个个体影响到他们的特定看法——好吧，我们制作东西不是为了某一个个人，我们是为了整个大众在创作，所以它不可能对所有人都管用，但这并不意味着它就有什么毛病。但我同时也发现，嗯，我觉得你对汇总数据的看法是对的，但与此同时，有没有哪些电影、作品或音乐明明得到了差评，而你却真的很喜欢？
Oh my God, yeah, of course. Can you think of one? Think of a film that's... Yeah, the New World, a Terrence Malick film, The New World, got not great reviews. Interstellar, Chris Nolan's film, not great reviews. Sean, what about you? I love those two films.
噢，天哪，有啊，当然有。你能举出一个例子吗？想想看哪部电影……对，《新世界》，泰伦斯·马力克的电影，《新世界》，评价就不太好。《星际穿越》，克里斯·诺兰的电影，评价也不太好。肖恩，你呢？我喜欢这两部电影。
Yeah, Interstellar's. I mean, I can't think of them, but I know that, or I'll look on Rotten Tomatoes and conversely. The latest Batman film, I thought, was incredible. Jesse, can you think of a film? I mostly have it with theater. I mostly have it with theater where I am enthralled by a piece and then I look online,
对，《星际穿越》是……我是说，我一时间想不起来，但我知道，或者我会去查烂番茄，反之亦然。最新那部《蝙蝠侠》电影，我觉得棒极了。杰西，你能想到哪部电影吗？我这种情况大多发生在戏剧上。我大多是在戏剧上遇到这种情况：我被某部作品深深迷住了，然后我上网一看，
I'm like, how is this torn apart? This is the greatest thing I've ever seen. Because there's something about, and I don't know, maybe that even has to do with different performances off for different things. I don't know. Yeah. But I do think that all the time.
心想：这怎么会被批得一无是处？这明明是我看过最棒的东西。因为这里面有些东西，我不知道，也许这甚至与不同的演出表现针对不同的东西有关。我不知道。对。但我经常会有这种感觉。
But I'll go the other way too. I feel the same way season three of Ned and Stacey. Sorry, go ahead Sean. I'll look at Rotten Tomatoes and something will get like 90% or 95%. And I'll watch it and I'm like, oh good, they did the work for me. It's gonna be great, right?
但我也会反过来想。我看《奈德和史黛西》第三季时也有同感。抱歉，肖恩你继续。我会去看烂番茄，然后某部作品得到了90%或95%的好评。我去看了，然后心想：噢太好了，他们替我把功课做好了。这肯定很棒，对吧？
Right, right. And it's terrible. I loved Tenet. Nobody, a lot of Tenet, the Crystal Lomovie got ruined. I've seen it three times. Right during COVID, it got lost, right? I loved it.
对，对，对。结果烂透了。我很喜欢《信条》。没人……很多人——克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影被毁了。我看过三遍。就在疫情期间，它被遗忘了，对吧？我很喜欢。
Sean, you didn't love it. I loved it. I didn't get it. Yeah, I didn three times. But during COVID, it got lost, right? I loved it. Sean, you didn't love it. I loved it. I didn't get it. Yeah, I didn't understand. You didn't love it. One more thing about the directing thing. Have you ever gotten a really crazy direction from a director?
肖恩，你不喜欢。我很喜欢。我没看懂。对，我没……你看过三遍。就在疫情期间，它被遗忘了，对吧？我很喜欢。肖恩，你不喜欢。我很喜欢。我没看懂。对，我没看懂。你才不喜欢呢。关于导演这事还有最后一件事。你有没有从导演那里得到过什么非常疯狂的指导？
That's A. Yeah. B, how has getting weird direction from directors affected the way in which you interface with actors? Also, being an actor yourself. And you've worked some incredible directors and I'm sure you've been able to cherry pick from the best of them and decided what not to do
这是A。B，从导演那里得到奇怪的指导，是如何影响你与演员互动的方方式式的？另外，你自己也是个演员。你和一些极为出色的导演合作过，我确信你能够从他们身上汲取精华，并决定不去做那些糟糕导演做的事。
from the bad ones. But was there one in particular moment where you're like, I will never ever do that to a poor actor or a crew member? Only my friend, like, Ruben Fleischer, who I think you guys know, like, you know, he just, oh, he did like the Zombieland movies and then we just did, Now You See Me Together. I've worked with him a lot.
但有没有那么一个特定的时刻，让你心想：我绝绝对对不会那样对待一个可怜的演员或剧组人员？只有我的朋友，比如鲁本·弗雷斯彻，我想你们也认识，你知道的，他执导了《僵尸之地》系列，然后我们最近一起合作了《惊天魔盗团》。我和他合作过很多次。
And I just remember on like the first Zombieland, we were shooting in like what was supposed to be like a mansion. And so he was like several rooms away on the monitor. And I just heard this muffled scream, now smile! And I was like, I could understand that he was kind of talking to me.
我记得在拍第一部《僵尸之地》时，我们在一个本该是豪宅的地方拍摄。他隔了好几个房间，坐在监视器前。我只听到一声闷声尖叫：现在笑！我当时就想，我能理解他大概是在对我说。
But also, I'm not like a smiler, you know, but also like, it can't come, that's not the way you act. Like, oh, my face will smile, you know. So that was just something I was like, oh yeah, I'll never do that. But I love Ruben and now he's great. But you guys have worked with Greg Metola, I think too.
但同时，我也不是那种没事就笑的人，你知道的，而且这种事，情绪不能这么演。就像，噢，我的脸会笑的，你知道吗。所以那件事让我觉得：噢，对，我绝不那样做。但我很喜欢鲁本，他现在人很好。不过你们也跟格雷格·莫托拉合作过，我想也是。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And he's just like my favorite. Like the way he handled the crew and the cast. And I had like, which happened to me maybe two or three times in my life, I had like kind of a panic attack during a scene and I just shut down and I just couldn't act. I don't know what happened, I just couldn't act.
对，对，对，对。他简直是我的最爱。他对待剧组和演员的方式。我曾经有一次——这在我一生中大概发生过两三次——在拍一场戏时经历了一种恐慌发作，我整个人直接崩溃了，根本无法演戏。我不知道发生了什么，我就是演不下去了。
And so it was on this movie, Adventureland, I took him aside and I said, I'm so sorry, I don't know what happened, I think I had a panic attack. And I thought he was going to say, well, you know, I thought he was going to respond annoyed. And he said, I don't understand how you're not having a panic attack every scene. Like, you're exposing yourself, you're bringing your emotions,
所以那是拍《冒险乐园》的时候，我把他拉到一边说：非常抱歉，我不知道怎么了，我觉得我恐慌发作了。我以为他会说，嗯，你知道的，我以为他会很不耐烦地回应。结果他说：我真不明白你为什么不是每场戏都恐慌发作。就像，你在袒露自己，你在注入自己的情感，
you're trying to not think about your own vanity. And I just remember thinking, that's the way I want not think about your own vanity. He is such a sweet man. And I just remember thinking, that's the way I want to think about actors forever, which is that they're already doing this difficult thing. They're trying to avoid thinking about their face being blown up on screen. They're avoiding thinking about the scrutiny
你在努力不去考虑自己的虚荣心。我记得我当时想：这就是我想……不去考虑自己的虚荣心。他真的是个太温柔的人了。我记得我当时想：这就是我对待演员的永恒方式，因为他们已经在做这件极其困难的事情了。他们在极力避免去想自己的脸被放大投影在大银幕上的样子。他们在回避去想将要面临的审视，
that they're gonna get. They're trying to live in the moment despite 100 stranger standing around them. And so that was a key for me. He's just the best, isn't he? Right, which is why I don't understand, for the most part, we actors are pretty crazy. And I'm talking about myself.
尽管周围站着100个陌生人，他们依然在努力活在当下。所以这对我来说是一个关键。他简直是最好的人，对吧？对，这就是为什么我搞不懂，大多数时候，我们演员都挺疯的。我是在说我自己。
I'm fucking nuts. And I'm filled with neuroses and insecurities. It is a helpful tool to pull, it's a helpful tool to call on when you're playing vulnerable characters. The central thing that we are doing, which is being up there in front of the camera, sort of is at odds with the inherent insecurities a lot of us have. So speak about that because again, getting back to you're so self-effacing and honest about your own neuroses. How were you possibly drawn to this incredibly, you know, exposing profession?
我他妈就是个疯子。我充满了神经质和不安全感。当你去扮演那些脆弱的角色时，这倒是一个很有用的调用工具。我们正在做的核心事情，也就是站在镜头前的那种状态，实际上与我们很多人内心的不安全感是相悖的。所以聊聊这个吧，因为再次回到你身上，你对自己神经质的剖析是如此自嘲和诚实。你怎么可能会被这个极具……你知道的，容易暴露自我的职业所吸引呢？
Because to me, to have like a prescribed way of behaving because of a character and lines, I feel so comfortable. Like the thing that makes me nervous is like you go into a party and what do I say to this person? Don't remember this person. What did this person tell me? Why do I have to be funny in this thing? I just want to go home.
因为对我来说，由于角色和台词的存在而有了一套规定的行为方式，这让我感到非常舒适。真正让我感到紧张的事情是，比如你去参加一个派对，我对这个人该说些什么？记不得这个人了。这个人刚刚跟我说了什么？为什么我在这件事上必须表现得幽默？我只想回家。
Like, to have like a prescribed way. Like, you're playing this character, they wear these pants that we put you in, and you have to now go talk to that other person in this voice. Like, oh yeah, this is the greatest thing in the world. It's much more calming, yeah. So calming.
所以，有了一套规定的方式……就像，你扮演这个角色，他们穿着我们为你挑的裤子，你现在必须用这种声调去跟另一个人说话。就像：噢，太棒了，这是世上最棒的事。这要安心得多，对吧。太安心了。
Now what about, I had the same feeling, and then I started doing talk shows when I was a kid, and it freaked me out because you have to be you. And there is no script. And it's like- And there is no you. Right, exactly. We talk about panic attacks, I'm prone to panic as well.
那……我有过同样的感受，然后当我还是个孩子的时候开始做脱口秀节目，这把我吓坏了，因为你必须做你自己。而且没有剧本。这就好像——而且没有“你”。对，没错。说到恐慌发作，我也很容易感到恐慌。
And talk shows for a long time were just like my kryptonite. It's the only thing that still freaks me out in our industry. Like literally nothing else but going on these talk shows at night freak me out because I don't, I can't be funny telling a story for like the second time. You know? I don't know.
很长一段时间里，脱口秀节目就像是我的克星。这是我们这个行业里唯一仍然会吓到我的东西。真的是除了这个，晚上上这些脱口秀节目是我仅有的会感到害怕的事，因为我不会……我没办法把一个故事绘声绘色地讲上第二遍。你知道吗？我不知道。
I've seen you on talk shows, Jesse. You're always, you kill it every time. Yeah, you're awesome. I agree, I've seen you too. Because I try to not tell the story on the show that I told to the person before the day. Because I know if I did that, it would just be weird and phony.
我见过你上脱口秀节目，杰西。你每次都表现得超级惊艳。对，你太棒了。我同意，我也见过你。因为我尽量不在节目上去讲我那天在节目开始前刚跟别人讲过的故事。因为我知道如果我那样做了，感觉就会变得很诡异、很虚假。
You'd be trying to remember what made them laugh on the phone. Kind of like a performance. But if you get a great host like Kimmel or Conan or those guys, they'll go with you, right? You can kind of freestyle and they can just get into a conversation and you forget you're even in front of people.
你得努力去回想是什么在电话里把他们逗笑的。有点像是一场表演。但如果你遇到一个棒极了的主持人，比如吉米尔、柯南或是那些家伙，他们会顺着你的思路来，对吧？你可以随性发挥，他们能顺势把天聊下去，让你甚至忘了自己正身处聚光灯下。
But you're doing this now, then you're doing Graham Norton. Do you ever get burnt out by all of the chatter that you have to come up with? I don't, I don't. I feel like an adrenaline rush when I'm meeting people like you who are really funny, and him, I'm sure he's very funny.
但你现在做完这个，接着又要上格雷厄姆·诺顿秀。你有没有对那些不得不即兴吐出的各种废话感到精疲力竭？我没有，完全没有。每当我遇到像你这样真正有趣的人，还有他——我相信他也非常有趣时，我都会感到一阵肾上腺素飙升。
You get the adrenaline rush of doing a thing that's fun. Right, and when you're promoting something that you love, like this great movie, A Real Pain, I'm sure it's just like you could talk all day about it. Yeah, I guess, yeah, because I've done junkets that we all have for things that have not gone well. And yeah, that can be really uncomfortable and you're kind of just parsing the evil.
你会有一种在做一件有趣的事情的肾上腺素飙升感。没错，当你宣传一件你热爱的事物时，比如这部伟大的电影《真正的痛苦》，我确信这就好像你可以一整天都在谈论它。是的，我想是的，因为我也做过那种大家都有过的、并不顺利的宣传采访。是的，那可能会非常尴尬，你只能勉强应付。
Before we let you go, I just wanted to find you on social media, if I wanted to find you on social media, what you're holding. Yeah, exactly, it's at the real. At the real. at the real. Yeah. At the real. Jesse, you're awesome. You're funny as shit.
在我们放你走之前，我只是想在社交媒体上找到你，如果我想在社交媒体上找到你，你拿着的是什么。对，没错，就是 at the real。At the real。at the real。对。At the real。杰西，你太棒了。你真他妈有趣。
You're talented as hell. Nice as ever. Thanks. Oh thanks. I love your show. Thank you so much for having me on it. Thank you buddy. Say hi to Karen and Daniel and Graham.
你简直才华横溢。人好得不得了。谢谢。噢，谢谢。我很喜欢你的节目。非常感谢你能邀请我来。谢谢你，老兄。代我向凯伦、丹尼尔和格雷厄姆问好。
Enjoy the rest of your day. Thank you very, very much for doing this buddy. Thank you so much guys. It's such a fucking pleasure having you dude. Oh yeah. Thank you. Such an honor too. Okay well hi.
享受你剩下的时光吧。非常非常感谢你做这一切，老兄。非常感谢你们，伙计们。能邀请你来真是他妈的荣幸，老兄。哦，耶。谢谢。这同样是我的荣幸。好吧，嗨。
Hi. Hi. Hi. Enjoy the rest of your day. Thank you very, very much for doing this, buddy. You're very busy right now. It's such a fucking pleasure having you, dude. Oh yeah, thank you, such an honor too. Okay, well have a great morning. Look forward to meeting you one day in person. Yeah, me too. All right, buddy, all right, enjoy. Bye bye.
嗨。嗨。嗨。享受你剩下的时光吧。非常非常感谢你做这一切，老兄。你现在真的很忙。能邀请你来真是他妈的荣幸，老兄。哦，耶，谢谢，同样感到荣幸。好吧，祝你有个美好的早晨。期待有一天能亲自见到你。是的，我也是。好的，老兄，好的，尽情享受吧。拜拜。
Now there's a nice fella. Love that guy. Yeah, he's really funny. Love that guy. I have no idea what to expect. Did you know him before this? Me neither, no. Now I want to. I have no idea what to expect. Did you know him before this? Me neither.
瞧，真是个不错的家伙。真喜欢这家伙。是的，他真的很有趣。真喜欢这家伙。我完全不知道会遇到什么。你之前认识他吗？我也不认识，不。现在我想认识了。我完全不知道会遇到什么。你之前认识他吗？我也不认识。
No, now I wanna do a lot of in person with him. I wanna find him at a party and corner him. Yeah. I know, I'm going to Cafe Clooney to have lunch with him next week. Hey, you don't, nice pipes, Will. Well, what part, Will just removed his sleeves. I know. Jesus.
不，现在我想和他做很多面对面的交流。我想在一个派对上找到他并把他堵在角落里。对。我知道，我下周要和他在克鲁尼咖啡馆吃午饭。嘿，你别，这身材真不错，威尔。威尔刚把袖子脱掉了。我懂。天哪。
I just rolled them up. Well, what part of your brain, what part of your brain came up with Ned and Stacey? I don't know. Well, that's the place where Will and I first met. That's where Jason and I first met on the set of Ned and Stacey. What are you talking about? That was the Debra Messing show.
我只是把它们卷起来了。威尔，你的大脑的哪个部分，你大脑的哪个部分想出了《耐德和史黛西》？我不知道。嗯，那是威尔和我初次相遇的地方。那是杰森和我初次相遇的地方，在《耐德和史黛西》的片场。你在说什么？那是黛布拉·梅辛的节目。
He was buddies. Yeah, correct. I was doing a guest shot on it, and Will was friends with Nadia. Dejani. Dejani. And we all went out for drinks after the show, as one does. And there I was with Will at the bar,
他是好朋友。对，没错。我在里面客串过，而威尔和娜迪亚是朋友。迪贾尼。迪贾尼。演出结束后我们都出去喝了一杯，就像大家常做的那样。然后我就和威尔在酒吧里，
apparently getting hammered because- We were getting hammered, and Jason had a very weak bladder because he kept going to the bathroom. Yeah. And- And it was years later that I said to Will after I had put down the bottle.
显然喝得烂醉，因为——我们在喝得烂醉，而杰森的膀胱非常虚弱，因为他不停地去洗手间。是的。而且——直到几年后，在我戒酒之后，我对威尔说，
Like seven years later. Yeah, I said to Will, and Will hadn't been drinking either for a long time, I said, boy, fuck, I wish you and I had really gotten together when we were drinking, you know, and we would have had so much fun. And he just looked at me and goes, oh, we did. And I had no recollection of partying with him that night.
大约七年之后。是的，我对威尔说，而威尔也已经很久没喝酒了，我说，天哪，他妈的，我真希望当初我们喝酒的时候你我真的能混在一起，你知道，我们一定会玩得超开心。他只是看着我说，哦，我们会的。而我完全不记得那天晚上曾和他一起狂欢过。
That's so funny. I love that Jesse. I mean, that Jesse Eisenberg, he's really left me in a great, great mood. High quality guy, high talent guy, high intelligence guy. The guy, he's a writer, he's an actor. I guess you could call him bi-talented. No?
太搞笑了。我太喜欢杰西了。我是说，那个杰西·艾森伯格，他真的让我拥有了一个非常非常美妙的心情。高品质的人，才华横溢的人，智商极高的人。这家伙，他是个作家，他是个演员。我想你可以称他为“双重才华”吧？不是吗？
Sorry, I'm trying not to go, I'm trying not to do the fucking Sean-y. Bi- like what? You do it, you do it, let's hear it. Okay. Bi-talented. Yeah, why is that, why do you go into that? It feels good, it feels really good in my throat.
抱歉，我在尽量克制自己，尽量不去模仿那个他妈的肖恩腔。“双重”像什么？你来一个，你来一个，让我们听听。好吧。“双重才华”。是的，为什么是这样，你为什么会变成那种腔调？感觉很好，在我的喉咙里感觉真的很棒。
Can we harmonize the bi-talented? Okay, ready, ready, go. One, two, three. Bi- No, someone's gotta go high, someone's gotta go Okay, ready, ready, go. One, two, three. By. No, someone's gotta go high, someone's gotta go low, someone's gotta go middle. I'll go middle. I'll go middle, you go high,
我们能把这个“双重才华”和声一下吗？好吧，准备，准备，开始。一，二，三。“双——”不，得有人唱高音，得有人唱——好吧，准备，准备，开始。一，二，三。“双——”不，得有人唱高音，得有人唱低音，得有人唱中音。我唱中音。我唱中音，你唱高音，
and Will will go low. Ready? Sean, you start. Okay, no, you gotta start at the base. By. By. By. Talented.
然后威尔唱低音。准备好了吗？肖恩，你开始。好吧，不，你得从低音开始。“双。”“双。”“双。”“才华。”
Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔马夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机手工打造。Smart。Less。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。